hello everyone welcome to the October
2022 ask me anything addition to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll delayed a little bit this month
usually we try to go for the first
Monday of the month with the amas but we
wanted to hit last week with TMA
aganabuzz podcast the beginning of World
space week since we were talking about
space and Timmy is a one of the former I
guess directors of world space week or
something like that so anyway here we
are with the AMA uh many things going on
just had a book come out you may have
heard the biggest ideas in the universe
space time and motion volume one of the
three volume Trilogy the book launch has
gone well I'm teaching courses at Johns
Hopkins and so forth so there's a lot
going on I don't want to waste too much
time with long introduction here just
wanted to say a huge thanks to everyone
who has been donating to the mindscape
big picture scholarship fund this is a
scholarship fund at bold.org that people
can apply for if they're in high school
or university and will be still
attending University in the future and
going to be studying to become someone
who studies the Big Ideas uh whether
it's physics or philosophy or math or
biology Neuroscience whatever but the
fundamental nature of reality in a deep
way if that's the kind of thing that you
want to study in college you could apply
for the mindscape big picture
scholarship if not you can always donate
money to the mindscape big picture
scholarship go to bold.org scholarships
slash mindscape and the very good news
is we're giving away scholarships that
will be ten thousand dollars each we
have enough to fund two scholarships and
we're actually very close to having
enough to fund three scholarships which
is amazing uh huge thanks to everyone
who's contributed you really I think
trying to make someone else's life
better in a really interesting and
different way for those of you who are
new around here these ask me anything
episodes are funded by patreons or
patrons I suppose of the mindset podcast
people who contribute on patreon if you
go to patreon.com Sean M Carroll you can
both get ad-free versions of the podcast
and also ask the questions that I will
go about answering right now so let's go
[Music]
I should start by saying that of course
we have too many questions as usual I
try to pick ones I think I can give
interesting answers to there are things
called priority questions once in your
life you're allowed to ask a question
that I promise I will do my best to
answer but also apparently this month
again this happens sometimes but patreon
cuts off some people's typing or
something like that there it seems that
there were a few questions that began
but didn't end so I'm not answering them
but just make sure to check once your
question is submitted whether or not
it's actually showing up before I go
about trying to answer them so to begin
then Ken wolf says I've been reading the
weirdest people in the world by Joseph
Henrik former mindscape guest one point
he makes early on is how profoundly the
spread of General literacy has changed
the way people think just one example is
how it makes us lean heavily lead toward
reductionist rather than holistic
thinking do you think that the spread of
literacy has been something close to an
unalloyed good or do you think that
something important might be
disappearing from The Human Condition as
we all move in that direction
I would say this is a very good question
of course I'm not an expert in this so
this is just you know me giving my
incredibly untutored personal take but I
think that it's not an unalloyed good
necessarily because most goods are not
unalloyed but I think that literacy is
an overwhelming good maybe there are
some disadvantages maybe it has made us
lead toward being reductionist lean
toward being reductionist but man it's
worth it literacy is one of the most
important things in the world so you
know how do you balance these things how
in the world do you even answer the
question is it worth it overall if you
have some disadvantages and some
advantages but I think that for literacy
the ability to read as someone who is
literally reading this question right
now and
someone who writes books someone who
writes articles all of these things of
course I'm going to say that literacy is
overwhelmingly advantageous you know if
you don't want to be literate you don't
have to learn I guess or you can forget
you can just stop reading that's okay
but I don't think many people are going
to be doing that
Jimmy says imagine you build a computer
that tells you whether a number is prime
outputting a one of its prime in a zero
if it's not imagine then that you put in
the number 13 and receive an output of
one you can then ask the question why
were those particles that represent an
output of one in that particular place
at that particular time you could answer
it by telling a story from The Big Bang
blah blah blah or you could say that it
was a mechanism designed to determine
primes the number 13 was input so they
represented an output of one
both explanations seem valid but are
they equal the sort of reductionist
going back to the Big Bang one versus
the higher level trying to get a prime
number one my intuition says that the
latter explanation is not just more
useful but in some way actually more
accurate what do you think
so I don't think that I quite agree with
your intuition but I get your intuition
I think that there are two ways of
talking about it you know I wrote a
whole book the big picture that talks
about poetic naturalism and the multiple
levels at which we can think about the
world all of which can be thought of as
valid so I don't think it makes much
sense really so I don't see the argument
for saying that the higher level
explanation that you say that the reason
why these things happen in a certain way
is because the number 13 is prime is
more valid it might be more explanatory
there you might imagine that there is
some sense in which we can rank the
explanatoriness of different
explanations by some version of how much
you get out versus how much you put in
right for the explanation in terms of
the big bang and the physics of
Elementary particles and so forth you
really actually have to put in a
tremendous amount of information before
you get out the prediction that the
computer will say one because 13 is
prime whereas if you just think about
abstract symbol manipulations and the
number 13 you don't need much input to
say yes this number is going to be prime
but that doesn't make it more valid more
valid you know validity is just as a
true or is it false right or does it
work or does it not that is not a
measure of efficiency I think maybe what
you're looking for is efficiency or
something like that and yeah I
absolutely think that levels of
explanation might have varying degrees
of efficiency and absolutely it makes
more sense if you're a computer
programmer to think of this level of
prime numbers not at the level of
Elementary particles and the Big Bang
Elliot spect says the web telescope has
recently been used to detect CO2 in the
atmosphere of an exoplanet to use this
result to calculate the probability of
finding life there we need the prior
probability we can use other data to
estimate the prior but basis theorem
applies all the way down so any
inference from observation ultimately
depends on a Credence developed with no
data whatsoever so how can I defend as
rational conclusions which depend on
data free credences well I think there's
two things one is a small footnote it's
not that the Credence is developed with
no data whatsoever the credences that we
develop as priors have something to do
with who we are in some very broad sense
our biology our psychology our
Neuroscience our education our
upbringing our intuitions The
evolutionary history that brought us
here we are embodied creatures living in
the world and that all counts as data in
some sense right we have experience with
the world we have a way of thinking
about things and these are are the way
these ways of thinking about things that
seem natural and intuitive to us feed
into our priors they're not completely
arbitrary priors
that's a footnote I think there's
nevertheless a point here which is that
there's just the primary worry about
Bayesian reasoning is that people start
with different priors that's true and
you're not going to get around that
because people do start with different
priors there's just no choice right I
mean that's just how reasoning works if
you want to say what is the chance that
some Theory I don't know is whether it's
true or not what is the chance that it's
true different people are going to have
different ideas that's not a bug that's
just a feature the rationality comes in
when you reason from the beginning point
of having that prior having priors that
are weird to the rest of us might be
unreasonable but are not irrational if
you know what I mean the rationality has
to do with the process that you use to
make logical deductions from those
starting points and Bayesian reasoning
is just the tool that you use when
you're dealing in situations of
uncertainty there's no real again
there's really no choice about it so you
can talk to other people about their
priors and you can sort of hand wave
yourself into arguing in favor of a
prior right you can say well you know
chemistry I've learned certain things
laws of physics it's a big universe
whatever it is and people may or may not
agree with you but if you collect enough
data the word enough is going to be
doing a lot of work here but if you
collect enough data good bayesians will
always converge on the same answers so
that's ultimately going to be the true
way to be rational about these things
Chris Murray says in one of the biggest
ideas in the universe videos you
mentioned that one of the things the
hamiltonian formulation of classical
mechanics does is allow P equals MV
momentum equals mass times velocity to
be not the definition of momentum but a
physical law we might violate is there
value in considering physical quantities
other than momentum in the same light
well maybe I'm answering this question
not because I have any brilliant Insight
on it but it's a it's a cool question so
I think it's an insightful question do
we know that certain things that we
Define aren't actually better thought of
as dependent variables that we should
think of as solving some equations
rather than just being defined to have
the values that they do
I don't think that physicists usually
think that way maybe maybe they should
maybe that'll be a useful way to think
but physicists very often will take
something they think is a constant and
say well what if it's a variable like
that's that happens all the time what if
Newton's constant of gravity is a
variable right that's what bronze and
Dickie did a while back to invent
bronsticky theory of gravity and and so
forth there's more examples like that in
the particular case of momentum equals
mass times velocity it is an implication
of hamiltonian mechanics but sorry the
fact that that equation is an equation
of motion rather than a definition is an
implication of hamiltonian mechanics but
I don't think that's the motivation that
you that led Hamilton to invent
hamiltonian mechanics I'm not exactly
sure what his motivation was but I think
that's a result that popped out so the
other reason I wouldn't answer this
question is just to sort of highlight
the difference between something turning
out to be true that we hit upon by some
line of reasoning and using that kind of
thing as a starting point right a
motivation so it worked for momentum
turning it from a definition into a free
variable that we could then solve as an
equation of motion but maybe or maybe
not it will work any other way so I'm
happy to let people try but I don't
think that we should be uh we should get
the impression necessarily that that is
a Surefire way to get better laws of
physics
nalita s says the money world's
interpretation of quantum mechanics is
mind-boggling and it kind of makes one
wonder about a mysterious phenomenon
that some lucky ones experience often
like seeing in one's head an event or
person as an image only to be followed
by the manifestation of that thought in
real life how would you as a physicist
and philosopher interpret those
mysterious events well I personally
would interpret them as having nothing
to do with quantum mechanics I think
that the brain and how the brain works
is way more complicated and way harder
to understand than quantum mechanics is
there's enough going on in the brain
that we know that number one we make
mistakes all the time we hallucinate
things we misperceive things you know
when linguists study how we comprehend
language whether it's listened to or
read on a piece of paper our brain is
constantly filling things in we're not
hearing every sound or reading every
letter likewise optical illusions are a
great example of where we see things and
our brain forces them in to a certain
kind of pattern even though the pattern
might not be the right one that's why it
turns out to be an illusion furthermore
retrospectively we often give greater
weight to things that we think are
surprising and cool and interesting and
provocative rather than objectively
collecting data in some you know numbers
of of
times that something happens versus how
many times you'd expect it to happen
like a good Bayesian so given that I
think there's plenty of reasons based on
the laws of physics to think that
quantum mechanics has nothing to do with
seeing things either that we that
haven't happened yet or that are
happening far away I think that I would
blame the tricks of the brain for that
rather than the rules of quantum
mechanics
covetin says could you help me
understand irrational numbers
specifically why do mathematicians give
importance to certain irrational numbers
like I and Pi but not others like x
divided by zero or does the fact that
the number is irrational tell us more
than the number itself why are these
numbers so important in physics so I
think that we've missed the definition
of a rational number here so irrational
numbers to mathematicians or physicists
don't just mean weird numbers or special
numbers that means specifically real
numbers so not imaginary ones like I the
square root of minus one and actual
numbers not like X over zero which is
not even a number but real numbers like
Pi or like the square root of 2 but
numbers that cannot be expressed as a
fraction of two integers right Pi is
very very close to 22 7 but 22 7 is the
ratio of two integers and Pi is not the
ratio of any two integers that's what
makes it an irrational number irrational
numbers are very very important if you
have some span of real numbers like all
the real numbers between one and two
almost all of them are irrational there
are far far more irrational numbers than
rational ones so why are they important
in physics and math just because they're
a crucial part of making up the
Continuum of the real line not to
mention the real plane or the real other
things anytime you have a Continuum
irrational numbers are a big part of the
game
Nicholas sherowski says I've heard you
say several times that you're glad to be
doing physics because it's much easier
than other Sciences however I sometimes
feel that natural scientists look down a
bit on other social sciences like
psychology sociology Linguistics Etc
because they have different
methodological foundations how would you
respond to someone who says sociology is
not a real or Genuine science
well I think that they're very different
activities sociology and physics but I
don't I definitely think they're both
science I mean to me science is at the
attempt to explain the World by
developing models and testing them
against data right that's what science
is and that those models can be about
Society or people or language just as
much about as about chemistry or physics
or whatever so someone who says
sociology is not a real science it's
just not paying attention or just trying
to start a fight or whatever I'm not
going to spend a lot of time uh arguing
with them now the reason why I say
physics is much easier than other
Sciences is somewhat tug and cheek of
course
actually becoming a physicist is not
necessarily easier than becoming any
other kind of scientist I would say that
becoming a really really good physicist
is about equal difficulty to becoming a
really really good linguist or
psychologist or whatever but that's
because human beings have certain
capacities and in any one of those
fields you sort of push your capacities
to the utmost and see how far you can
get what's easier in physics really is
not just becoming a professional
physicist but making progress that's the
real thing that characterizes physics
it's way easier to make progress because
physics very often deals with very
simple systems a pendulum rocking back
and forth an electron field vibrating
whatever it is very very simple compared
to society or the human brain or the
structure of language and so forth so
that's why physics seems hard because we
can learn a lot about it because we're
able to make progress by studying simple
systems which is not possible elsewhere
and for someone just to say that
something that does aspire to thinking
about and hypothesizing and saying true
things about very very complicated
systems like psychology or sociology Etc
is just uh not paying attention I think
now having said that of course it's
always possible to say that a certain
field of endeavor is on average not
doing nearly as well as it could at its
own aspirations right you could say that
there are just methodological flaws in
Psychology or sociology just like you
can say their methodological flaws in
physics but if you want to say that you
gotta say exactly what those flaws are
and you got to back it up by actually
having some evidence in favor of that
claim
I'm going to
group together two questions here
because they're the same question and
then they just came out of of somewhere
Sugar Pine press says could you please
spend a little time unpacking the fine
structure constant is it significant
that it has no units does a theoretical
Multiverse anthropic argument truly
reduce it to you know no big deal does
it play any role in your thinking about
what space time emerges from and then
Nick G says is there something unique or
special that differentiates the fine
structure constant from the coupling
constants of other forces seems like
there's one unique constant for each
Force yet the fine structure constant
gets all the hype so the fine structure
constant is is like is being implied
here part of a list of constants of
nature that we have in let's say the
standard model of particle physics all
the causes of nature I guess not all of
them but it's weird how different they
all are in some in some sense you know
the fine structure constant is
interesting because it is dimensionless
so it's a number which means that it
doesn't depend on what units you use to
measure it everyone should agree that
the fine structure constant once you
tell me its definition has the value
approximately 1 over 137 whereas
Newton's constant of gravity depending
on what units you use will have
different forms different numerical
values it is not the only constant in
the standard model of particle physics
that has it that is dimensionless but
the others you know have different sort
of statuses so like for the weak
interactions you know that the weak
interactions are unified with the
electromagnetic interactions and there's
two more numbers that come in there one
is the expectation value of the Higgs
field and that is a dimension full
quantity and that's a puzzle we don't
understand why it has the value it does
the other is What's called the weak
mixing angle or the Weinberg angle and
that is dimensionless but it's an angle
which means that it can only possibly
take on values between let's say 0 and
Pi because it wraps around and it's sort
of equal to itself if it goes past Pi so
it's a little bit different than just
the number like the the fine structure
constant an angle has a constraint that
the fine structure constant doesn't but
I do think that to actually get at the
question
there is a lot of historical analysis
going on here we figured out
electromagnetism and in particular we
figured out Quantum electromagnetism
before we figured out any of the quantum
theories of the other fundamental forces
so it popped out that we had this
dimensionless number in QED Quantum
electrodynamics before we knew really
what to say about the other ones I
should also mention the strong
interactions which in some sense also
have a dimensionless number associated
with them but it's harder to tell you
what that number is because in Quantum
field Theory numbers that are coupling
constants depend on the scale at which
you measure them
and for the fine structure constant of
electromagnetism you can just take the
limit as you're measuring it at zero
energy and to find that to be the number
at higher energies the number would
change a little bit according to the
renormalization group but with the
strong interactions the number seems to
blow up at Zero Energy so what you do
instead is say what is the energy scale
at which the strong interaction
coupling constant Becomes of order one
and that is called the qcd scale and
it's a dimensional Dimension full number
it is a around a third of a gev a third
of the mass of the proton so even though
in some way of thinking classically at
the level of the lagrangian if you want
to put it that way the strong coupling
constant is dimensionless you really
need to Dimension full number to specify
what it is so it's really the fine
structure constant that is the most
obviously dimensionless of any of the
fundamental structure constants I don't
think that it means that it has any
fundamental role in quantum gravity or
anything like that it's about
electromagnetism is I think that's the
right way to think about it
okay Nick Mike Michael I'm sorry it says
here Michael as if it were Michael but
with an N so I'm going to assume that
it's just correct uh and this is Michael
Kramer says despite reading all the
popular accounts of the Higgs field that
I can find I'm afraid I still don't
quite understand how it adds Mass to the
affected particles most of these
accounts describe the field and how it
interacts with the affected particles
but then it seems that Presto the
particle has mass can you help me out
here well I don't know if I can help you
out or not I'm the author of one of
those popular accounts of the Higgs
field so I I do my best but and and the
the problem is that I'm not sure what it
is about those accounts that is leaving
you cold or leaving you uh unsatisfied
so I'm not sure that I'll be able to
patch up that particular hole but here's
a way of thinking about it that might be
a little bit different than what we
normally think you know what is mass
after all so basically I think the right
way to think about mass is what Einstein
taught us that E equals m c squared mass
is a kind of energy it's the energy an
object has when it's just sitting there
not doing anything right no kinetic
energy no potential energy just has
existence energy and that energy is
that's mass times the speed of light
squared or rather what we call the mass
is that rest energy divided by the speed
of light squared so where does it come
from why does a particle in fundamental
physics have energy when it's just
sitting there well if particles are
massless when we well I guess the right
thing to say is this in modern physics
all these particles come from Fields
it's not just the Higgs boson that is a
field the electron is a field the quarks
or Fields all of these things are fields
and they're vibrating fields and the
vibrations have different kinds of
energy associated with them there's
kinetic energy which means the fields
time derivative gives you a kind of
energy how fast is it vibrating there's
gradient energy how is the field
changing from place to place that's a
kind of energy and there's also
potential energy and the potential
energy is not how the field is changing
from place to place but just what is the
energy associated with the value of the
field so you might think in your mind
that the field has zero value it has
zero energy and if it has a non-zero
value maybe it does have an energy okay
that's not always exactly right in fact
famously for the Higgs boson that's not
true the energy is not zero at zero
field value that's why the Higgs field
takes on a non-zero value in empty space
the lowest energy state is not at zero
field value but this is any that that
story is true for all of the fields so
the photon is massless and it doesn't
have any potential energy at the field
level the mass of a field comes from its
potential energy and you can this is not
going to be very satisfying maybe but
you can kind of see that connection
Einstein says the mass of an object is
the energy it has just sitting there
Quantum field Theory says the mass of a
field is the energy you get just from
having a value not necessarily from
changing but for something like the
photon there's no potential energy
there's no no energy associated with the
field having a value in fact the value
of the field this is the the something
that is wrapped up in what we call gauge
invariance or gauge symmetry the value
of the field doesn't matter only how the
field changes from place to place and
indeed when you get into the math only
certain aspects of how it changes from
place to place is what really matters so
the field for electromagnetism is not
the electric field or the magnetic field
it is the what we call the vector
potential field which gives rise to the
electric field the magnetic field
depending on how it's changing over
space or over time so because there is
no actual energy associated with the
value of the field it has no potential
and it has no mass and that's why the
photon is massless
the electron field in its low energy
state has a potential energy so if you
just try to push the field uniformly
everywhere that costs you energy and
that's a reflection of the fact that at
the quantum level the relevant the
associated particles are going to have
mass
so if you buy that which you may or may
not uh then it all becomes very very
simple there's a fundamental way of
thinking about the electron where it
didn't have any potential energy where
the value of the field wasn't giving you
any contribution of the energy but
there's an interaction between the
electron and the Higgs field so that the
value of the electron field does bump
into the value of the Higgs and when the
value of the Higgs was Zero that was
just an interaction it was a way for the
Higgs field to literally scatter off of
electrons and so forth but when the
Higgs field gets a non-zero value in the
vacuum what used to be an interaction
now becomes a potential energy because
the electron field is interacting with
the Higgs field it now costs energy to
change the value of the electron field
so now there's a potential energy for it
and guess what that turns into a Mass
for the associated particle you have to
kind of take on faith that there is a
leap from quantized fields to particles
but that is a leap you better be
prepared to make or read one of the
various things I've written about it in
one of my books
okay I'm going to once again group two
questions together Chris Shipton says is
it possible for a black hole to spin so
fast it would tear itself apart and
Johann Falk says does a spinning black
hole not have completely not have a
completely spherical boundary so no and
yes spinning black holes well it depends
you mean by spherical the boundary The
Event Horizon of a black hole has the
topology of a sphere but it can look
like a squashed sphere if the black hole
is spinning a spinning black hole will
generally have the geometry of an oblate
spheroid much like the Earth but much
more perfect than the earth because the
Earth is kind of lumpy it is not so
pulse it is not possible for Black Hole
to spin so fast to tear itself apart but
there is a limit that you reach where is
it's the fastest a black hole can spin
and this is what is called an extremal
black hole so if a black hole starts to
spin there's sort of an upper limit
where it is no longer a black hole if
you go past that limit then you would
get like a naked Singularity or
something bad like that so in practice
what happens is you you can't reach that
point right you can start with an
ordinary black hole and try to add spin
to it but how do you add spin to it you
have to throw something into it that is
spinning and so you're adding not only
spin to it you're also adding more
energy to it or more mass and you never
get to the point where the spin is more
important than the mass and that's what
you would have to do to reach this
extremal point but really all I'm saying
here is Google extremal black holes
there are extremo black holes both in
the case of spin where you say there's
so much spin it's almost trying to
overcome the gravity and there's also
extremely black holes in the case of
electric charge where you say you know
there's an electric field that is
pushing things away that is almost ready
to overcome the strength of gravity but
in both cases you can't get there that
is part of the cosmic censorship
conjecture which you could also look up
if you're interested
Dylan Hall says I've watched several of
your talks on finding gravity in
space-time in quantum mechanics and also
a few lectures from Leonard suskin on
SpaceTime being created by entanglement
could space-time being created by
entanglement provide any explanation of
inflation or the initial low entropy
state of the universe if we start with
no entanglement and allow things to
start entangling what happens
you know they might be related but I
don't think that there is any immediate
explanation from that because it's
almost implicit in your second question
if we start with no entanglement and it
allowed things as aren't entangling uh
well we can do that but why did we do
that why did you start the initial state
of the universe with no entanglement
there's also I think we're gonna get to
this later on but whether a Quantum
state is entangled or not is actually
not a well-posed question you have to
take a Quantum system and you have to
divide it into subsystems and then you
can ask whether those subsystems are
entangled or not that's a well-posed
question but entanglement has to be
between two different things so if you
talk about the wave function of the
universe which is only one thing and you
say is it entangled that's kind of a
meaningless question so this is just a
footnote to say that you have to be a
little bit careful when you even say
these statements is it's not that there
is a statement with no state with no
entanglement there is a set of substates
that are not entangled with each other
now it's very possible that that is the
correct way to think about the early
universe and its expansion I've actually
written a couple of papers that say
exactly that one on Quantum circuit
cosmology and the other on decider space
as a tensor Network a way of thinking
about entangled Quantum bits and it's an
interesting possibility but it does not
as far as I know provide any easy ways
or or novel ways of addressing the
fine-tuning problems of the early
Universe even in even if you are
thinking of space is Created from
quantum entanglement you still have to
just posit the fact that that
entanglement had a certain structure at
Early times now that might just be that
none of us has thought of the right
answer yet so that's why I'm answering
this question I'm hoping that someone
out there thinks of the right answer
then you can you know have an
acknowledgment or a citation in your
paper talking about this podcast
Eli Graham says many of us who have
personally suffered homophobia in our
academic and professional lives were
quite moved by your comments in the last
AMA regarding renaming the web telescope
in my own case as recently as less than
20 years ago I brought to the attention
of the director of the school where I
taught homophobic attacks Against Me by
another teacher the director not only
refused to help me he let me know I
should be grateful the school even hired
gay people that was some improvement
over earlier years when I we expected it
worse to go to jail and it best to lose
our jobs and professional reputations
for being gay the question is what
realistically can your listeners do to
get the telescope renamed so I'm sorry
to hear about those experiences Eli and
I know that it's not just 20 years ago
things like that still happen hopefully
they're becoming more rare but they're
absolutely out there and it's terrible
it's
not a good reflection on us as human
beings that we choose to be biased and
discriminated uh and discriminating
against people in that way so I do want
to take it seriously I do want to ask
you know how we can make things better
and I think that we make things better
not by ignoring the problem but by
talking about it and trying to actively
improve the situation
um
however having said all that if your
actual question is what can we do to get
the telescope renamed and you you did
put the word in there realistically I
think realistically there's almost
nothing I think realistically that ship
has sailed I would I would like it so
again as I said last month I am not a
super expert on James Webb or how he
behaved my very tiny experience with
reading about the claims about him made
it seem perfectly plausible that he was
a nasty person especially when it came
to gay people and that he either let
them be discriminated against or
actively participated into it and I
think that's bad and I don't think that
we should be honoring that kind of
person for
um with telescope names but you know
maybe there's history there that I don't
know so I'm not trying to make new
substantive claims about that my claim
is that if someone is that kind of
person we should not be naming
telescopes after them but we did name we
the Royal we I had nothing to do with it
but NASA named the telescope after him
and I I don't see any realistic way to
get it the name changed just because
bureaucracies are bureaucracies and
they're not easy to change so what I
would say is
um
the telescope being named after someone
who was homophobic or anti-gay is not
good but maybe we can make something
good out of it you know rather than
trying to think the the best about how
we can possibly get the name changed
which might be banging our heads against
a wall we can just be noisy about the
fact that people like that should not be
celebrated and it's still a problem
right now
um and maybe the ongoing name stuck to
the telescope can continue to be a
reason to talk about that and let people
know about it and not let the issue fade
from a popular view of course I could be
wrong about this maybe my you know uh
judging of the political wins is
completely wrong and NASA is going to
change the name tomorrow which would be
great if that's what they decide to do
but that is what my judgment is right
now I don't think it's the best way to
expend our energies to try to get the
name of this telescope changed
Brendan Hall says what do you think
about the finale of lost I kind of liked
it but I know many didn't so yeah I know
that not only not all of you have
watched the TV show Lost I did all the
way up to the finale
um so I wouldn't answer the question if
I thought that it was going to be
completely meaningless to people who
hadn't seen the TV show but lost is sort
of a paradigm for TV shows not ending
well and I think it's a very interesting
question when you you know TV show
especially a long-running network show
is kind of a unique storytelling
challenge because stories are very often
shaped by how they end right the end of
a story is kind of an important thing
but when you're in season three of a TV
show and you don't know how many seasons
you're going to get and it's not just a
sitcom where you just tell jokes every
week where there's supposed to be some
dramatic tension and movement from place
to place from moment to moment from
episode episode from season to season it
can be really challenging to set
yourself up for a successful finale
especially because you often don't even
know and so I mean sometimes you're told
the year is canceled after you finished
doing a season and there's no real
finale at all
um and especially for something like
lost where a lot of the interest of the
show was a set of mysteries right uh a
mystery of all the genres that you can
think of has to have a payoff at the end
and so I'm pretty sure if my
understanding is correct I actually
helped interview uh Carlton cues and uh
Damon Lindelof who did the show the
showrunners and I think they didn't know
what all of the things that were going
to be happening were like halfway
through the show running like they would
set some things up and then try to come
up with good explanations for them after
the fact that is not necessarily a bad
strategy
um but it can backfire and I think that
in the case of lost they just couldn't
come up with a ending that would make
everybody happy but you know maybe there
wasn't an ending that would make any
everybody happy and another famous
example of a TV show not nailing The
Landing is How I Met Your Mother which
is a which is a sitcom but it kind of in
season one set up this big mystery you
know who was the mother of the children
and how did they meet and it sort of
promised an answer but that was in
season one and things changed after
season one and they were stuck with that
answer they felt that they were stuck
with that answer and couldn't wriggle
out of it even though it was entirely
inappropriate by the time they got to
the final season so anyway this is just
interesting to talk about in my mind
because I I'm fascinated by storytelling
and I'm fascinated by the methodology of
coming up with how to structure a story
and and to best tell it and
the cases when it doesn't work are just
as important as the cases when it works
and you know look Game of Thrones is
another example where I thought that the
early seasons were some of the best
television ever made and the last season
ruined it all which was really kind of
almost an accomplishment in in itself so
I'm I would like to know if there is a
better theory of making finales for TV
shows
Peter Bamber says with respect to
dangerous evil and powerful people who
can make life miserable for many others
should we always await arrest and trial
before deciding upon a sentence or is it
sometimes better to save misery to save
Misery by means of assassination
I think this question is is
both good and important and far too
vague to be possibly answered it just
depends enormously on what we're talking
about here you know I do think that in a
functioning Civil Society one should let
the rule of law do its job one should
not take justice into one's own hands
um but I also know that not every
society is well functioning right and
it's when Society is not well
functioning that sometimes you do have
to take things into your own hands like
for an interesting case and one I'm
gonna I know I'm gonna be in trouble
saying this but I'm gonna say it anyway
the January 16th uh riots right the
Insurrection the uh terrorist attack on
the capital of the United States January
6th people make a big deal out of that
and I think correctly so it was a
terrible thing that happened but what if
we are trying to be careful and honest
and say what the origin of the
terribleness was and I think a lot of
people would say well look they hacked
the capital of the United States that's
a terrible thing but you know
what if the election truly had been
stolen what if one party had just
somehow managed to
fix all the voting machines to give
themselves a victory that was not an
actual reflection of what the voters had
done what if they had truly stolen the
election now they obviously didn't in
the case of the 2020 election but what
if they had right what if one party had
just set itself up for permanent rule by
not by campaigning and winning the votes
but by controlling the voting machines
then I think that people would have some
right slash obligation to protest maybe
even violently against that right so in
some very real sense January 6th was a
terrible horrible thing it should be
living
embarrassment and ill repute for
everyone concerned for the rest of their
lives but the origin of the Badness
isn't the attack it's the fact that they
promulgated and believed that lie about
the election being stolen that was the
problem things follow from that that are
terrible but that was the beginning of
it so anyway which is all just to say
with respect to Peter's question
um if we did live in a society which
purported to be a democracy but was not
really a democracy and all of the votes
were rigged then I think it'd be
perfectly Justified to go to none
peaceful means to try to fix things
the really sad thing of course at the
end of this discourse is that someone
has to make that decision and often the
people making that decision are not very
good or smart or having the best
interests of everyone else at heart
which is why so many extrajudicial
actions are bad rather than good
all right let me uh speaking of
controversial topics let me group
together a bunch of things these are all
follow-ups to the AMA question I had
last month about a clone of Alice the
criminal so Robert ruxandrescue says in
the last AMA you covered a case where
Alice does something terrible but dies
before she gets the punishment you argue
that if a new instance of her is created
she's basically the same person so she
can serve the sentence but if that's the
case here's my proposal I get to do
whatever I want murder steal etc for
each of my crimes I create an identical
copy of myself and give the copy to the
authorities
this is an identical copy of myself you
can take this copy to prison to serve my
sentence I propose this way I serve the
sentence for my crimes while I the
original version can roam around do
whatever I want
Constantine ianonu
uh ianu sorry
says priority question during September
2022 AMA you answered positively in the
below question by Anonymous although it
is contrary to intuition as accepted by
you my question is whether you would
maintain the same position in the
possible scenario that multiple accurate
clones of Alice are created would they
all have to be held accountable
Johann Falk says concerning the
hypothetical Alice in the September AMA
I would argue that convicting her for
the crime only seems wrong if one sees
the conviction as a punishment or
Revenge if one sees the rule of law not
as a way of getting back at offenders
but as a way of shaping Society it makes
perfect sense to convict her it assures
that people acting in the way Alice did
are taken care of in best case they are
rehabilitated and helped to a better way
of living their lives do you see any
benefits of thinking in terms of Revenge
or punishment apart from giving any
giving any victim some kind of
satisfaction and finally linu mizyara
says in the latest AMA there's a
question about a person who commits a
crime dot dot dot now suppose the person
who commits the crime is still alive and
is arrested if there are 10 identical
clones of that person who don't have the
faintest idea that a crime is being
perpetrated do you think these 10 people
should be arrested too so
some preliminary remarks before tackling
all these questions which are slightly
different questions about the same
scenario remember the original scenario
was Alice is committed a crime she is
killed with an identical clone of her is
created should we be able to punish the
Clone for Alice's crimes I chose to
interpret the question and you can
interpret in different ways but I chose
to interpret it as the clone of Alice is
really an identical copy of Alice before
she died so not just a clone not just
with the same DNA but a person with
exactly the same psychology in exactly
the same memories basically an atom for
atom copy of what Alice was like
I don't think the whole point of my
answer was I don't think there's any
essence of self-identity that follows
the actual physical atoms of a person
that doesn't make sense to me you know
we're all exchanging our atoms with the
environment all the time and if I think
if I literally construct a copy of
someone Adam by Adam they're for all
intents and purposes they contain the
same responsibilities and weight of
history that the other person did so to
line miziara's question what if this
these other clones don't have the famous
idea crime has been perpetrated that's
clearly not what I was talking about I'm
not talking about just clones who have a
completely different memories then I
wouldn't punish them that would be crazy
I'm only talking about punishing people
who actually in their minds have the
memories of the person who just
committed the crime you know in their
minds they are the person who just
committed the crime and I think that all
if if you think that it anyone deserves
punishment then all such people deserves
punishment so for Johan's question are
we doing it for revenge or punishment
versus possible Rehabilitation and
deterrence purposes I think I'm very
much in favor of consequentialism here
we should do it for deterrence and
Rehabilitation purposes we're trying to
make the world better not just getting
some sense of Revenge so therefore
if we're trying to deter people from
doing it and we're trying to
rehabilitate the people who do do bad
things that's why I think that all the
people in exactly the same mental state
as the criminal should be given that
punishment there's no sort of
metaphysical correctness to which person
deserves the punishment and then
um to Constantine's question uh if the
person is still alive and multiple
accurate clones of Alice are created
they all have to be held accountable
sure
again they're all in their minds guilty
of this crime they are the person whose
mental state caused them to do this
crime and therefore if they're if any
one of them is worth having uh being
incarcerated or whatever then they all
are and then to Robert's question uh if
I make an identical copy of myself can I
just say well punish them no the
punishment should be every person who
has that mental state deserves the
punishment it's not like if you punish
one person it's like you know you can't
punish an identical twin and say that
counts if the other person's twin
actually did the crime so the whole
Spirit of my answer which again you're
free to disagree with as always but the
spirit of my answer was
people do not have metaphysical Essences
okay that sort of cease to exist when
they die people are processes people are
collections of matter acting in certain
ways and if I have a collection of
matter that is indistinguishable in
every microscopic way from another
collection of matter both of these
collections of matter look like people
with certain memories then whatever way
we should treat one of those collections
of matter we should also treat the other
one that is the major point that I want
to make you can disagree about how we
should treat any of them but they should
all be treated the same
Nick nech volidov says why do scientists
and interested parties such as myself
accept the findings of experiments using
the Large Hadron Collider when the
findings can't be replicated with
independent apparatuses well I think
there's lots of reasons for one they can
to some extent be replicated because
there's more than one detector at the
Large Hadron Collider there are two
large general purpose detectors the CMS
detector and the atlas detector and this
was in fact historically crucially
important to why we accepted the
discovery of the Higgs boson so quickly
because both experiments saw it in
exactly the same place doing exactly the
same things so they do in fact use the
same source of protons in the Large
Hadron Collider okay but still they're
doing different measurements of those
protons and that's almost a completely
independent experiment but the other is
you know even if there were only one of
them you would have less Credence on the
results if there were only one of them
but still you would just be a good
Bayesian right your credences would
depend on what your prior was the
discovery of the Higgs boson is
something where everyone thought it
should happen more or less sooner rather
than later and so we were ready to
believe it faster than light neutrinos
or something that no one believed so
people are very skeptical of even though
it's also coming out of CERN so you just
try your best to say well what are the
chances that these people would get it
right get it wrong whatever are they
good they have a track record have they
convinced us that they're being honest
with their backgrounds all these things
you can do
for the more general question of how do
people who are not experts choose to
have
um belief that a certain scientific
experiment is wrong is is on the right
track at all you know I think that you
have to again use your judgment but we
tend to trust the the opinions of people
who are experts I'm a Believer in
expertise experts are never 100 correct
but they're more likely to be correct
than non-experts are so I think that the
fact that all the particle physicists in
the world more or less accepted that the
LHC is on the right track should be
taken as evidence that not it certainly
is but that it probably is
Oria Biddle says it may be a natural
outgrowth of poetic naturalism that I
often hear you mark that you don't like
to debate things you give an impression
that you're perfectly fine with people
believing whatever they believe and just
giving your take as you currently see it
do you ever find a time where you think
it's appropriate to Hash some
disagreement out or dig deep into why
you and someone else see things
differently is it only in private at
dinners with a few drinks in you well I
think there's a couple things going on
here in this question so I enjoyed uh
being on the debate team in high school
and I certainly appreciate the reason
why people like doing it and I do think
it's also good training both for public
speaking and for logical thinking what
it's not especially good at is a way to
find the truth
it depends a lot on who's doing the
debating what the format is all those
kinds of things when I participate in
debates these days which is rarely but
sometimes it happens it's not really a
fact-finding mission in time trying to
figure out how the universe works right
it's more entertainment and inspiration
for the audience usually if I'm going to
participate in a debate it's because I
think that I can get a message out to
people who otherwise might not hear that
message under different circumstances
but the what you're asking in the
question is sort of more about whether
it's appropriate to hash out some
disagreement I mean that's not something
that I'm averse to doing at all but
that's not having a debate that I think
that's a huge mistake to conflate the
idea of hashing out a disagreement or
digging deeply into why I and someone
else see things differently versus
having a debate a debate is very formal
very artificial you know it's it's again
it's more entertainment than
intellectual exercise I spend my whole
life hashing out disagreements and
digging deep into why I and someone else
see things differently that's what
academics do all the time every day so I
I do I do that you know quite frequently
now having said that you still have only
24 hours in the day you have to choose
what are the disagreements that you're
going to dig into and I would just much
rather engage with people who I think
are also acting in good faith trying to
learn something trying to improve their
own understanding rather than people who
are just trying to sort of demolish a
debate opponent okay so there are people
out there who are already convinced they
have the right answers and their job is
just destroy the other side and that's
an exercise in which I have no interest
at all
Clyde Schechter says I'm confused about
pulsars after the explanation in the
Chiara mingarelli episode we see these
objects because they're rapid rotation
oblique to the axis of their magnetic
field creates electromagnetic radiation
but with its radiation going out the
Pulsar must somehow lose energy my my
first thought is that the rotation would
slow but then their pulse intervals
would be Progressive would progressively
lengthen and they would not be The
Marvelous Ultra regular clocks they are
I assume energy is in fact conserved
somehow how does that happen
yeah this is a very good question but of
course energy is conserved in this
particular case I'm well known as
someone who appreciates that there are
some cases in which it's not exactly
true but this is a very good case where
it is and they do slow down it's a
well-known fact that pulsars slow down
over time but two things the Slowdown is
very very tiny so there's a quantitative
question here you can't just say well
they slow down how come that doesn't
ruin them their use as clocks uh you can
understand how quickly they slow down
and take that into consideration when
they're when they're being used as
clocks and the Slowdown is very very
tiny there's a lot of energy available
in that spin of the pulsar and only a
tiny amount of it leaks out through
giving out all of this radiation
Benjamin F says do you agree with David
Deutsch's interpretation of why we see
an interference pattern in the double
slit experiment he claims we are
observing a tangible Photon from our
universe being interfered with by a
phantom Photon from a parallel universe
that differs from our universe only by
the position of that single Photon if
Deutsche is correct is some kind of
communication between worlds
theoretically possible you know this is
an area it's a very good question
because it's an area where people who
all agree that many worlds is the best
way of thinking about things like I do
and David Deutsch does can never less
disagree about the best way to attach
words to what is going on in many worlds
I say specifically attach words because
we all agree on the math There's no
distinction and no disagreement about
how to use the equations but how best to
interpret them in terms of words changes
from person to person and in particular
what I would say is you can have a
quantum mechanical State representing a
single universe and then you say that a
certain part of the universe a certain
system within the universe has a single
Quantum State and then it becomes
entangled with its environment we call
that decoherence and then its wave
function branches and now there are two
different copies of it in two different
universes that is a way of talking but
another way of talking is to sort of
take the system before it Deco hears and
talk as if it's already two different
universes they just haven't branched yet
okay and that's more like the way that
Deutsch is talking I don't think that's
a good way of talking because in
principle things can branch in different
ways sort of along different axes when
you when you look at a system that is
not yet decohered that has not yet
become entangled with the environment
there's no unique unique way to divide
it up into a collection of different
universes it's just one thing is the way
that I would put it but anyway
I kind of don't care like people this is
a Live and Let Live situation as far as
I'm concerned because we all agree on
what the equations are telling us
Bill Quirk says many believe that the
expanding Universe requires a departure
from unitarity in quantum mechanics do
you think a departure Community is
needed
so what is being referred to here is
unitarity is the quantum mechanical way
of saying conservation of information
unitarity is the idea that you have a
wave function it evolves from one point
in time to another point in time in a
way that if you know where it ends up
you can figure out where it came from
it's just reversibility in the quantum
context so the amount of information you
need to specify is the same at Early
times and later times naively you might
worry that the expansion of the universe
has some conflict or at least some
tension with this because the universe
gets bigger there's more stuff for at
least more room for stuff and therefore
maybe you need more information need
more room to tell you exactly what is
going on in that particular Quantum
state so I think there's lots of things
to say about this the ultimate answer is
we don't know at face value I think that
that particular tension is overblown it
comes from our intuition not from the
equations there's no necessary reason
just because the universe is expanding
that you need to violate unitarity but
that's not to say that you don't you
know it's a situation where you have
quantum mechanics you have gravity there
are Mysteries here not only quantum
gravity and the emergence of space and
time but as we already talked about the
mystery of the initial conditions and so
forth so here is a case where
I'm open to thinking outside the box and
thinking about ways to go beyond the
standard Quantum story and just but just
to to mention uh this would be a pretty
big departure from the standard Quantum
story if unitarity we're not part of the
story so you want to be really sure that
you have a good reason to go beyond it
or at least a even better way of
thinking lined up as an alternative if
you want to go in that direction
Jesse rimler says the Russian invasion
of Ukraine is a horrific crime and
Russia is responsible I believe the
ukrainians are right to ask for Aid and
it is right for the U.S to supply
Ukraine with Aid I also believe it is
right for the U.S to apply pressure to
initiate peace talks critics call this
appeasement but I don't see many
grappling with where this conflict is
headed one expert who does is anatol
live in at the Quincy Institute under
the current policy he sees a high chance
for a decades-long conflict similar to
Pakistan and Kashmir or an escalation to
the brink of nuclear war neither would
be good outcome outcome for Ukraine to
put it mildly do you think the U.S
should use its influence to step to help
initiate peace talks well
it depends on what you mean by peace
talks you know peace talks are always a
good idea I think that peace is better
than War but when you have peace talks
presumably you're trying to come to some
agreement right you're saying well we'll
have peace if you do this and we do this
that's where all of the hard part is
what is it going to take to have an
agreement that both sides can agree to
right now I see essentially zero chance
that Ukraine and Russia are going to
agree on any peace uh
um a peace agreement I'm just saying the
word agree over over again that's why
I'm hesitating here but I think that
their differences are too large and and
that just makes sense because Russia
invaded them to you know take over them
and it didn't work uh as I will say now
what I always say here that the United
States can think whatever it wants what
has to matter the most is what people in
Ukraine want they're the ones who are
being invaded okay so I don't see any
ukrainians asking the U.S to negotiate a
peace settlement right now so I don't
think that we really have the right to
demand such a thing now
there is a footnote there which is of
course that everyone's interests are in
not having a nuclear war that is
absolutely true
um so I do think that we should take
action if we think that there is
something to be done to prevent a
nuclear war that would otherwise have
too high a probability the problem with
that is I don't feel that I have a good
grasp on what that is what the
probability for nuclear war is or what
the actions are that would decrease it
if we set a precedent that nuclear
powers can invade other countries and
get what they want uh I don't think that
letting that precedent be set
necessarily decreases the chances for
nuclear war down the line so I think you
have to think past this one conflict and
think about all the possible
ramifications obviously Russians know
the Russians in power know that if they
launched a nuclear attack things would
go badly for them very quickly uh very
soon and so in some sense we're still in
the mutually assured destruction phase
of nuclear power although not exactly
because we're not really thinking of
complete destruction of another country
the Russia is unlikely to attack the
United States using nuclear warheads for
exactly that reason but they might think
they can get away with it in Ukraine I
don't think that they can I think that
it probably is uh better for the United
States and every other country in the
world just to emphasize the terrible
terrible consequences of anyone using
nuclear weapons in a first strike for
any reason that seems to me a more
stable long-term useful policy than
trying to uh broker a peace agreement
that the country that was invaded is not
in favor of
Paul says can science save us I have
very low expectations the world will
effectively deal with climate change if
you had the proverbial unlimited budget
what technology or experts would you
recommend
you know I don't have an unlimited
budget I don't even have unlimited or
even very big knowledge about what
technology would be the best when it
comes to climate change there's one very
very obvious technology which is not
even a technology it's just stop spewing
greenhouse gases into the air that's
something we know how to do so I would
prioritize that that's not to say we
can't do other things as well I'm
entirely in favor of doing technological
and scientific development on ways that
we can remove greenhouse gases from the
air that that sounds like a very
Obviously good thing to do but it's not
a replacement for stopping putting them
there in the first place so as far as
what the Technologies are I really have
no idea some combination of chemistry
and synthetic biology and things like
that might be of help but I'm not the
one to ask about it
Chris says if a telescope similar to the
James Webb Space Telescope was at the
other end of our galaxy or halfway
across the universe and it was looking
in the general direction of Earth would
it be able to determine that life
intelligent life exists here
um probably not is the short answer I'm
not going to give you a detailed answer
here because this is a quantitative
question at what distance from Earth
would the jwst be able to determine that
there might be life or intelligent life
here so I don't know the answer to that
question it's really not something that
this telescope is optimized for it so
happens that as an infrared telescope
with very high resolution it turns out
to be pretty good
for thinking for measuring Spectra of
atmospheres around exoplanets now that
we know there are exoplanets that's a
very good instrument to have but
specifically figuring out whether there
is life on them requires a lot more
knowledge we don't know in general terms
what kind of signature life will have we
have some rough ideas we have some
guesses but look we had guesses about
what kind of solar systems there would
be and those turned out to be half right
half wrong if you go back to the John
Johnson uh podcast that we did you know
our expectations weren't completely on
the ball so we don't even know what
exactly it is we're looking for I will
say that if the telescope is literally
at the other end of the Galaxy or
halfway across the universe that is too
far away that's why I can definitively
answer that especially because the other
end of the Galaxy you have to look
through the entire galaxy which is not
transparent there's a lot of gas and
dust and clouds in the way and halfway
across the universe is just too far away
so I think that for nearer exoplanets
jwst will be able to tell us something
but it'll be hints and indications it
will not be anything uh cut and dried is
my guess
David Maxwell says are there aspects of
Eastern philosophy that you actively
consider research or teach I've
re-listened to episode 160 with Edward
slingerland more than any other and
would love to see some more on Eastern
philosophy so roughly speaking no but on
the other hand you know it depends what
you mean by Eastern philosophy
um typically when you say things like
that Eastern philosophy you kind of mean
ancient Eastern philosophy I mean I
definitely read and cite
philosophers who are currently in China
or Japan does that count as Eastern
philosophy or of Chinese or Japanese or
other Asian extraction Indian Etc but
that's usually not what people have in
mind when they say Eastern philosophy uh
so as far as ancient Eastern philosophy
is concerned I don't really actively
consider research or teach it but I
don't really actively consider research
or teach ancient Western philosophy
either I will sometimes refer to it for
pedagogical reasons thinking that people
might be a little bit
um familiar with it or for historical
reasons you know there's a line of
development from Aristotle through
Galileo Etc that is interesting to talk
about but I don't search The Works of
the ancient philosophers in the West for
wisdom for our current ERA
um whether it's my at least I should say
about that about my own personal
research in natural philosophy if you
want to call it that or philosophy of
physics now I do think that when it
comes to sort of human scale questions
there's you're much more likely to get
something out useful and interesting out
of ancient philosophy whether it be
Eastern or Western that's just not my
personal area of Interest or expertise
so I don't lean in that direction
Sandeep chitale says can you please
explain why the low entropy at the Big
Bang is the cause of the direction of
the flow of time or maybe that is not
true I can see how the corollary is true
entropy generally increases in the
direction of the flow of time but cannot
see why the converse will be true well
this depends on what you mean by the
flow of time at the level of fundamental
physics there's no thing called the flow
of time you know the equations of
fundamental physics just use time as a
label it's not something that flows any
more than space flows the laws of
physics relate what happens at different
points of space and time to what happens
at other points in space and time I
would argue that the flow of time is an
impression that we human beings have
psychologically and every psychological
impression that we have ultimately comes
down to the thermodynamic Arrow of time
the fact that entropy is increasing this
is a longer discussion of course I did
have a couple of podcasts that about it
one with Janine Ismail my current Johns
Hopkins colleague also Dean bonamano we
talked about it and maybe a little bit
with David Eagleman The Psychology and
Neuroscience of time and its
relationship to entropy we know
something about the past that we don't
know about the future ultimately because
the entropy was lower we feel that we
have causal influence over the future
but not the past again because entropy
is increasing toward the future all this
is a very long story that I'm not going
to answer right now but that's how it
ties in if it weren't for entropy
increasing we wouldn't have any
conscious experiences including the
conscious experience that time is
Flowing around us
Jim Wade says does an entity have to be
alive to have intelligence
I like this question because it confused
me a little bit at first because not
confused me in the sense of like I have
no idea what the answer is but I thought
I knew what the answer was I kept
changing my mind so my first response
intuitively was well of course like if
you're not alive then how could you be
intelligent but then I thought about
what about artificial intelligence right
so this is clearly where I was just
being too naive I do think that
um there can very well be artificial
things which we would not classify as
alive but we would classify as doing
intelligent things now do we classify
them as having intelligence at this
point what I would do in my I put on my
philosopher hat and say that the right
thing to do is not to insist on trying
to answer a question does an entity have
to be alive to have intelligence but
rather taking a step back and thinking
about what we mean by being alive and
having intelligence so this is usually
the right strategy for these kinds of
questions when it's refusing to think
about these things the mistake might be
that we're assuming there is something
univalent out there called having
intelligence and another univalent clear
rigorous thing called being alive and
we're asking do they match up in some
nice way but you know as we learned from
Stuart Bartlett talking about what it
means to be alive there's more than one
aspect that is involved in being alive
and as we talked about many different
times in many different ways there's
certainly more than one aspect to being
intelligent right so I would say that
the better question to ask is what are
the ways in which the characteristics
that are associated with being alive are
or are not related to the
characteristics of having or not having
intelligence if you have a computer that
can play Tic-tac-toe and will always win
is that having intelligence
who cares it's an ability right the
computer I would not classify as alive
just because it could win in tic-tac-toe
but there's a relationship there that is
worth exploring but let's not be tricked
into thinking these words have meanings
even before we start thinking about them
Bob Polk says if I understand entropy
correctly it is a relational phenomenon
entropy is high only in relation to
where it is low somewhere else if this
is correct and following from this would
it ever be possible to measure the total
coarse grained entropy of the internal
states of a full human being as separate
from its external States using a kind of
Markov blanket approach Allah Carl
friston's work with the free energy
principle said another way could we
imagine one day having a Star Trek try
quarter to scan the high low entropy
reading of just one person moment to
moment so there's a lot going on here
first and foremost entropy is not a
relational phenomenon there is for any
given system you know for there's
different systems of course but a given
system
in a given course screening is just at
high entropy or low entropy full stop
the pause there is because you need a
course granting you need a pre-existing
way of thinking about what are what
which states are classified as living in
the same macro state or
indistinguishable from each other and as
we've discussed many times this is
something essentially everyone agrees on
but we have to agree on it okay that's
it's not just given by Nature there are
reasons why certain course grainings are
chosen that nature suggests to us but
ultimately we have to choose a core
screening and once we do that entropy is
a number that you calculate and it
doesn't have to be related to anything
else for the rest of your question I'm
not quite sure where that question
intersects with the ability to build a
tricorder that would scan our entropy
um I don't think that entropy is the
kind of thing you would want to scan
what I think is true is that that there
are macro States right so there's things
we can measure
um you know if you had a tricorder maybe
you could see what configuration a
person's heart or lungs were in or
something like that and that has some
macroscopic shape right the heart is
beating or whatever the lungs are
breathing but then there's a microscopic
set of things going on and those things
are going to be pretty close to
equilibrium right if they're if they're
at a certain temperature or whatever
they are maximum entropy up to their
macroscopic constraints to a very good
approximation that's not exactly going
to be true that's an approximation it's
a way of thinking about things but I'm
not sure what one would learn by
thinking about the internal state of a
person in terms of their entropy let's
put it this way I don't think the
different people you meet on the street
have very different entropies inside
them
Chris shatard says
there is something Kiara mingarelli said
that blows my mind that the very first
black holes might just have been pure
curvature with no matter in them you
even went so far suggesting such animals
might still exist now I'm slowly coming
to the realization that you don't need
matter to create a black hole and that
the gr equations allow for empty pure
curvature beasts but then pulling this
thread leads to weird questions would
these black holes necessarily have a
singularity and Event Horizon a Hawking
radiation if the answers are yes then
following the no hair theorem how would
you distinguish between matter-filled
black holes from empty black holes seen
from the outside of their Event Horizon
so yeah I mean it's absolutely possible
to make black holes in general
relativity without having any matter
because gravitational waves and similar
kinds of distortions of space-time can
effectively have energy right we know
that because black holes or other things
that spiral into each other the system
of the binary black hole is losing
energy to the gravitational waves that
it's giving off so the waves are
definitely carrying energy and that
means that if you get the right
concentration of gravitational waves
intersecting each other they can Collide
and make a black hole that's something
we can absolutely imagine happening
having said that Gravity by itself is
still a very weak Force so the chances
that this happens are is very small
chances are very small it's not going to
happen very much in the real world the
black holes that we have we can imagine
they're being created completely by
gravity but we don't think it's going to
be the most common thing
having said all that if it did happen
you have zero way of knowing that
they're the same outside that's the
consequence of the no hair theorems
black holes look the same given a
certain amount of mass Spin and charge
it doesn't matter what they're made out
of black holes are not solid objects
inside they're just space time inside so
there's no difference between a black
hole that was created by gravitational
waves colliding versus a black hole that
was created by a star collapsing or
something like that
Gary Upshaw says in your solo talking
about parallel lines you said to launch
two lines perpendicular to a line
segment at each end of the line segment
and keep them straight mathematically
what is straight in a curved space
means what we call a geodesic that is to
say the shortest distance path or the
extremal distance path let's put it that
way if you want more I did write a book
about this called the biggest ideas in
the universe space time in motion and I
do talk about what these geodesics are
one way of thinking about is the
following which I say this is literally
right from the book if you take two
trees and you tie a string between the
two trees and you pull it taut that will
make a straight line okay everyone
agrees
also if you take two trees and you stand
at one of them and you point yourself in
the direction of the other one and you
just keep walking forward you will also
describe a straight line so
mathematically those are two very
different procedures one the shortest
distance path That's What You Get by
pulling the string taut the other
started to point and keep walking
forward
either one of them can be used to define
what you think of as a geodesic if the
background in which you're moving is
curved itself to an outside Observer
neither one of them will look straight
but they are the closest analog to what
we have as straight lines in euclidean
geometry and that's what we mean in
general relativity Etc
Jim Watson says how do we think our
biology Evolution would be different if
the Earth had significantly different
frequency in its solar energy Cycles EG
tidally locked with the Sun or a day
that was an order of magnitude longer or
a year that was an order of magnitude
shorter and how do energy Cycles
influence the Goldilocks zone in the Hun
for life-supporting exoplanets
good question which I'm mostly bringing
up because I don't know what the answer
is I think this is the kind of thing we
should be thinking about when we're
thinking about life on other planets I
think that it doesn't affect how we
think about the Goldilocks zone very
much but also I think that the idea of
the Goldilocks has been somewhat
deprecated in the thinking of
exobiologists you know it used to be you
would have a star and you would say well
if you were too close to the star in
your orbit or too far away you'd either
be too hot or Too Cold on your planet
these days we realize that even here in
the solar system some of the most
promising venues for Life appearing are
places like the moons of Jupiter or
Saturn which might be have might have
been considered in the old days outside
the Goldilocks zone so we're going to be
a little bit more open-minded about
where life could actually be
the thing that is relevant I know why
you're asking the question if you have a
planet that is rotating with a fairly
rapid day then even though it will be
hotter during the day and colder during
the night they will both be pretty close
to each other astronomically speaking
because the planet keeps moving whereas
if the planet is tidally locked then one
side is going to get very hot and the
other will be very very cold there will
therefore by continuity be a region in
between uh where things are more or less
a similar kind of temperatures as they
are here on Earth in fact there was a
whole uh science fiction novel written
about this by Charlie Jane Anders one of
our former mindscape guests so you're
encouraged to look that up if you want
to know more about it but at this time
it just is science fiction we don't have
any hard data about it so we can
speculate about it I'm not very
knowledgeable about whatever
professional level speculations are
actually going on but it's fun to think
about
Kathy Seeger says when gravitational
waves are detected with ligo or the
Pulsar timing method how do scientists
gather information about the specifics
and localization of the system that
produced them well this is a good
question and it's a little bit tricky
because gravitational waves you know
don't form an image that's not how we're
looking at them like we do with Optical
or other kind of electromagnetic
radiation but what we can do is have
telescopes in different locations
pointed at in different orientations and
so forth right you remember that ligo
has two observatories one in Louisiana
and one in Washington state and they
team up with the Virgo detector in
Europe and hopefully soon some southern
hemisphere detectors and so as a
gravitational wave passes by it will
intersect the different detectors at
different times and you can use that
information to kind of triangulate where
things are on the sky having said that
it's not very accurate to compare 2
Optical or ordinary electromagnetic
things you can't pinpoint exactly where
they are you get kind of a blob
depending on what kind of signal you
have and we're trying to get better at
figuring out exactly how to localize
gravitational wave signals on the sky
I'm going to group two questions
together Joy kolbeck says how do you
personally visualize the Interiors of
black holes and Stevie CPW says do black
holes have defined edges and do the
holes have a bottom or are they
infinitely bottomless so I will answer
Stevie's question first here because I
think that this is stemming from a
misapprehension that black holes are
holes
they're really not you know we visualize
a hole in the ground as something that
has a bottom uh but it's still sort of
embedded in our three-dimensional space
where we have holes and things like that
a black hole is a region of space-time
or it's okay to think of it as at each
time it's a region of space but it's a
spherical region of space right there's
a boundary around it the Event Horizon
you can see the black hole or you can
you know notice it from all different
orientations and it looks round roundish
maybe oblate and inside of it there will
be whatever made it a collapsing star or
whatever that's you can't get there
typically because you'll enter and
you'll be crushed by The Singularity but
if you hurry up maybe you can reach the
collapsing star depending on how things
are but anyway from the inside to answer
Joy's question uh it looks the same as
it does from the outside if you pass by
The Event Horizon of a black hole you
wouldn't notice this at least within
classical general relativity the
prediction is you wouldn't notice you
might remember that there are debates
about firewalls at the boundaries of
black holes but most people don't think
that they're they're uh we're trying to
get rid of the firewalls in certain
calculations so if that's true once you
enter into a black hole you don't even
notice
a black hole is defined as a region of
space-time from which you can't escape
but you notice that that definition is
kind of forward pointing right you
cannot Escape As you move into the
future so at the moment when you're
inside the black hole you don't even
know you know that you're following some
trajectory and things are space time is
getting more and more curved and in your
future probably relatively quickly
you'll be crushed as the tidal forces of
the gravitational field rip you to
pieces but it's still just space time
around you there's no sign saying you've
now entered a black hole
David Boardman says how would you
distinguish scientific claims to
knowledge from non-scientific ones
you know I don't think there's
necessarily a single pithy motto that
functions as a bright line between
scientific claims and non-scientific
ones roughly speaking scientific claims
are ones that stem from thinking
scientifically and doing the scientific
process to establish your claims you
hypothesize things you come up with
different conjectures that might be true
whether you want to call them theories
or models or hypotheses doesn't really
matter and then you test them against
experience against data right the
primary so there's two primary things
that go on there both of which are
highly non-trivial one is you
hypothesize different things you don't
assume that you know it ahead of time
right you don't just think you have the
right answer you admit that you don't
have the final answer and you
contemplate alternative possibilities
and second is you judge those
possibilities on the basis of data
whether it's observation or experiment
or whatever in other words once again
you don't just think your way into the
ants answer that's what really makes it
scientific the ability to maybe be wrong
and the judging of whether you're right
or wrong on the basis of comparison with
your experience of the real world
Harry uden friend says in a past episode
you mentioned that there was no
conservation of energy in a changing
space time and pointed us to a paper
that you wrote many years ago in episode
2001 secrets of Einstein's equation you
discussed how an early version of the
Einstein equation for general relativity
was incorrect because of an error having
to do with violating the law of
conservation of energy can you please
help me understand this apparent
inconsistency sure
it just comes from the fact that
conservation of energy can mean
different things in different contexts
once we have general relativity on the
scene there is a rule in general
relativity for how energy changes in
response to gravity in response to the
curvature of space-time the geometry of
space-time and that rule is sometimes
called conservation of energy but it's
not simply saying that there's something
called Energy and you add it up all
through space and it's a constant okay
it's rather covariant conservation of
energy which means that the energy might
not be constant but it varies in a very
very specific predictable way in
relationship to how space time itself is
varying so we call it conservation of
energy even though it's not just energy
is conserved I hope that that's accurate
enough as to be Illuminating even though
it might not make you very happy that is
those are the words we use it all comes
down to uh the vocabulary we use again
the ideas are perfectly clear once you
know what they are
Giles from Melbourne says with Judea
Pearl from memory you both seem to
dismiss the idea that Aristotle's causes
were the same as those we were
interested in in English
can you expand on that at all in
particular whether the main difference
might simply be the cause and effect in
Modern English didn't don't exist at the
same time whereas Aristotle's examples
can exist at the same time fathers
children bronze statue Etc yeah you know
I think that it's a slight
misapprehension to think that
Aristotle's four causes are causes as in
cause and effect relationships that we
have Aristotle had a much more expansive
notion and of course he also wasn't
speaking English he was speaking ancient
Greek so we have translated his idea
into four causes but you know one of his
ideas is the reason for which things are
built which is not really the kind of
cause that we have when we're talking
about cause and effects as in the glass
fell over because I swung my arm and I
bumped into it so it's just a vocabulary
kind of difference you know Aristotle
was trying to understand change in a
very general way he didn't have modern
physics he did didn't have the idea that
you know we have objects with locations
that obey differential equations he
didn't have calculus so he didn't have
differential equations so he just had a
very different way of thinking and he
wasn't necessarily distinguishing
between changes uh you know biological
changes and physical changes changes
because we want them to happen changes
because we push them in some way changes
because there are natural ways of things
changing he wanted to distinguish
between them in the way that he found
most fruitful but as I said before most
ancient philosophy is not of much use to
Modern physics and his classification
doesn't really carry over to the way
that we think about modern physics
Casey Mahone says whenever we put on the
brakes in our cars the energy has to get
dissipated as waste heat do we have any
idea how much processes like this
contribute to global warming rather than
CO2 emissions
I think there's a couple things to say
you know again this is not my area of
expertise so if you want quantitative
relationships between different
contributors to global warming you've
come to the wrong place but there's
nevertheless a few things we can say for
one when we put the brakes on our cars
that's not even the greatest contributor
of heat from our car right the engine in
a typical internal combustion engine is
putting out a lot more waste heat than
the brakes are but the other thing which
is probably more relevant here is that
global warming doesn't mostly come from
heat it's a little counter-intuitive you
might think that we're warming up the
planet because we're burning a lot of
things and therefore raising the
temperature but that's not really the
problem you know we get the problem is
that we get energy from the Sun it heats
up us here on Earth and then in
equilibrium we give back the same amount
of energy to the rest of the world okay
but the
wavelengths of light are different we
get primarily visible light from the sun
and we radiate back primarily infrared
light to the Earth so that's the origin
of the greenhouse effect is that you can
put
things gases into the atmosphere that
are transparent to visible light like
CO2 so the visible light from the sun
that is heating this up just comes right
through whereas they are opaque or at
least more absorptive to infrared light
so the infrared light that we want to
radiate back to the sky gets caught in
the atmosphere if the atmosphere is
transparent to both infrared and visible
then you don't get this warming effect
but if you block in some of the infrared
eventually it will get out but it takes
longer in the process it heats up the
planet so it's that change of
transmittivity of infrared light that is
the single most important contributor
here the whole atmosphere is very very
complex system and that is a cartoonish
kind of version of it but it's the point
is it's not coming directly from us
generating heat it's from not letting
the radiation from that heat escape to
the outside world
Johann Falk says considering
utilitarianism and weighing outcomes
against each other it seems that putting
numbers on how good or bad something is
gives non-acceptable consequences such
as killing an innocent person is okay if
it results in a million people getting
an ice cream or something what happens
if we don't put numbers on outcomes but
only have them ranked as better worse or
roughly equal to each other could that
be a base for utilitarianism where a lot
of small good things never outweigh a
single very bad thing to me it seems
attractive but I don't know philosophy
well enough to know where such ideas
would get stuck or can't start
contradicting themselves uh by feeling
you know I'm not really utilitarian so
I'm certainly not an expert on the best
way to be utilitarian but I think that
the the feeling is that no
um simply ranking good and bad things is
not good enough because the whole point
of utilitarianism is to try to provide a
way of comparing situations where you do
have many little Goods versus one big
good and the idea of utilitarianism is
is very much sympathetic to the idea
that in some circumstances many little
Goods can be better than one big good so
you need a way to be able to figure out
exactly how many little Goods you need
to overcome the joy of one big good
right so therefore just ranking the
goods is not going to be enough you need
a way to quantify them that's what makes
it utilitarianism now that might not be
your philosophy that's okay maybe you're
not a utilitarian and you want to think
some other way but I think that it's
very plausible that there are
circumstances where an ordinary person
would say yes I like these small Goods
in their Collective goodness Better Than
This One Singular good okay that's just
a comparison people need to be able to
make one way or the other even if it's
not simply from adding up some utility
you have to be able to do that
comparison and simply ranking Goods
um in some order is not going to be able
not going to be good enough to do that
Andrew Goldstein says do you regard
gender as a social contract construct
and do you think it is founded on a
post-modernism view of reality adding
little to analytical or empirical
knowledge uh yeah I absolutely think of
gender as a social construct almost
everything that we talk about is a
social construct tables and chairs are
social constructs you know the Earth and
Jupiter are social constructs those are
social constructs that refer to
something real in the world but before
human beings there is no such word out
there as planet or table or anything
like that these ideas these concepts are
ways that human beings divide up the
world into stuff and those ways of
dividing the world up into stuff might
be more or less helpful or useful for
the purposes of human beings but they
are nevertheless ideas that people came
up with they were constructed by Society
okay so social construct doesn't mean
made up or illusory or fake if you
listen to the podcast we did with Sally
hesslinger she will explain exactly that
so gender is absolutely one of the
things that is a social construct and
that's that's not surprising that's the
least surprising thing in the world
um so I don't know what you mean but I
found it only postmodernism view of
reality adding little to analytical or
empirical knowledge I think that the if
anything if you want to sort of really
oversimplify the idea of post-modernism
which was sort of a collection of many
different things and impossible to
simplify
um it was pointing out the fact that
reality may or may not exist but our
ways of talking about reality are ways
that we invent and that's an important
distinction and one that should not be
alighted because it gives people a way
of manipulating reality and maybe you
don't want to let them do that but
admitting that it happens when you
invent language is kind of an important
step to not letting them do that so
post-modernists were not saying uh at
least sometimes they were not saying
that we can just say whatever we want
that was never the idea of
post-modernism but it was appreciating
the role that human choices make and
human desires and goals have when it
comes to how we choose to conceptualize
reality and I think that Insight can be
very very important when it's used
correctly
Michael koppelman says can you explain
what you mean when you say we quantize
things it implies to me you make
discrete in some way yet you say things
like space and time are not discreet so
what's going on yeah this is a very good
question that just arises from the fact
that the word quantize is a very very
inappropriate word once again physicists
using words in ways that are not always
immediately transparent so quantizing
has nothing whatsoever to do with making
discrete quantum mechanics doesn't have
anything fundamentally doing to do with
making things discrete and if anything
it's the opposite quantum mechanics
turns everything into waves okay but
then those waves find themselves under
certain circumstances with certain
discrete set of wavelengths you know
just like the waves that you make when
you pluck a violin string or a guitar
have a fundamental frequency and then
overtones or harmonics same thing with
the waves that we find that are wave
functions of particles in atoms or
things like that so even though quantum
mechanics says the world is
fundamentally mentally made of waves
there are aspects of it that appear
quantize be quantized because of the
specific shapes that those waves have so
when we say we quantize things we do not
mean at all we make a discrete we just
mean we take a classical system and we
correspond it correspond it it's not
exactly the word we associate it with a
quantum theory it is not a very
well-defined procedure actually there's
there are ambiguities there but the idea
is that we can start with a classical
model and turn it into a quantum
mechanical model that's what a physicist
means when it says we quantize something
Dale echo says I have health anxiety
that causes me to have panic attacks
gives me hypochondria Etc I love physics
but have noticed it can be a trigger for
me I was watching a video on null
geodesics and I got a sense of
existential dread that led to a panic
attack just from the enormity of space
and limits of my mortality when it comes
to exploring it is anxiety something
you've ever had and is there anything
you can do to come to terms with how we
as humans fit into something that exists
at such an immense scale
well I think it's a complicated question
you know I don't want to get into
advising other people on um their
anxieties and things like that I think
that's a personal thing that you should
talk with with professionals and loved
ones and so forth
um I'm sorry to hear about panic attacks
Etc that it that is um a shame and I I
don't really have any great way of
dealing with it you know I have had much
milder than that worries sometimes about
the existential issues that come up when
one thinks about the cosmos and its
enormity and I've often told the story
of when I was young you know trying to
go to sleep and eventually coming across
the question well I was just thinking
about physics or whatever uh like what
if the universe hadn't even existed and
that would be it that would that would
be make me worry and and feel like I was
small and insignificant but that was a
long time ago I don't really feel like
that anymore you know I think it is the
universe we live in I think that
um anxiety if we're if we're get to the
the point where we can be perfectly
rational about it there is no rational
reason to feel anxious because this is
our world this is just what the world is
um it's once something that should be
accepted we are very very tiny compared
to the world our lifetimes are very very
short compared to the world that
shouldn't be a sense of anxiety that
should just be a source of anxiety that
should just be something that we learn
and I I want to say you know that we
sort of cherish and and learn to
appreciate but even that is kind of a
choice right if you don't want to
cherish it that's fine but it is
absolutely something that we should
accept one way or the other I
unfortunately don't have any great
advice on how to do that if you're
struggling with it sorry about that I
wish I could be more help
Nathan dun and Gian says
what do you believe is the biggest
societal problem today how do you go
about addressing the problem what do you
wish people did differently with respect
to the problem
I don't know yeah the problem with this
question is that depends what we mean by
societal problem you know I'm kind of
worried about nuclear war that we
already talked about before or
bioterrorism or you know a giant Sun
flare that taking out the entire power
grid on the earth there's a whole bunch
of things that we can worry about not to
mention global warming and things like
that but those are not specifically
societal problems I think I think if I
have to say anything you know about
societal problems remember the podcast
with Brad Delong where we talked about
the changes in humanity due to the long
20th Century's Innovations one of which
was globalization and the others that he
highlights are the modern Corporation
and the research laboratory
um and you know globalization has had
many many benefits that you know Brad's
whole book is called slouching toward
Utopia because the irony that he points
to is the fact that we for the first
time in human history in some sense gave
ourselves the capacity to create Utopia
but then certainly did not do it in very
very obvious ways so I think that I
don't know if this is just cheap
philosophizing or theorizing but again
certainly not an expert in this I think
that people dimly perceive that as a
human race we have generated an enormous
amount of wealth over the last one or
two hundred years and not everyone is
participating in this wealth and not
primarily talking about inequality I
think that there's problems with
inequality but I don't mind the
existence of rich people I mind the
existence of people who don't who are
not rich I might I I mind the fact that
not everyone is Rich that's what I mind
I wouldn't mind if people some people
were much richer than others if everyone
were rich but not everyone is Rich there
are people in the world today who are
super duper poor even in advanced
societies that should be able to do
better and it's not even sort of total
amount of material Goods that is the
problem it's the feeling of
powerlessness that I think is the
problem I had to pick a single societal
problem is the fact that we have
arranged things in our society where too
many people feel there's nothing they
can do to control their environment
they're subject to forces that are much
greater than themselves and either
politically or economically or
culturally things are sort of out of
their control and this is reflected in
the fact that they maybe are not doing
so well off economically but also that
they're in debt right they it's not just
that they're not getting a lot of income
but even if they get income it goes to
paying off a debt whether it's college
student loans which hopefully we're
getting rid of some of them here in the
US but then we'll just get more
generation later but other kinds of debt
also mortgages and things like that and
it all feeds into this idea that when
you're under debt you're beholden to
other people and you're not in control
of yourself jobs are changing you know I
do believe that it's kind of inevitable
that when we have progress and economic
growth the set of jobs that are
available for people to have will not be
the same from generation to generation
that's inevitable and that's okay we
have to learn to deal with it but
dealing with it is hard and when you
feel like you can't be gainfully
employed and make a career out of the
kind of job that you grew up imagining
you would someday have that is an issue
that we haven't done a lot of good in
addressing people get sick they can't
control their health care they lose a
lot of money I think you know there's
just a lot of ways in which modern
society has figured out to suck the
resources from a large number of people
and funnel it to a small number of
people and again if that were in some
John rawlsy incense if that process were
to the better of everyone that would be
fine but it's clearly not and so I think
that people's lack of control over their
own lives in various aspects is probably
the biggest societal problem we have it
leads to things like less faith in
democracy and I think that is
potentially super duper disastrous
James aitchinson says
does the Everett many worlds
interpretation have implications for
practical reason and morality should I
be more prudent if billions of future
Meads will enjoy the future I make well
so I don't think that um Everett has
many if any implications for practical
reason and morality so roughly speaking
the way that I would put it is quantum
mechanics means that observers agents
human beings people cannot predict the
future exactly okay there is a lack of
determinism in the real world there are
certain things that are just going to be
probabilistic
but it doesn't really matter for
purposes of practical reason and
morality whether those probabilities
come from many worlds or for some other
interpretation of quantum mechanics
um
there is a metaphysical difference
because in many worlds there will be
worlds in which the different outcomes
all happen with probability one whereas
in a single Universe with stochastic
laws there's only a single universe and
all you can say about it is the
probability of certain things happening
in it but if you are either
a deontologist or a consequentialist I
don't see necessarily what that
metaphysical difference does to your
moral or ethical or practical
calculations I think that you know in
terms of if the most obvious example is
just being utilitarian
um
clearly it seems to me if I Branch the
wave function in two I should not double
the utility of the universe that would
mean that the most moral thing to do in
the world is just branching the wave
function of the universe which seems
completely silly because literally no
one else would even notice it if I was
like in a lab measuring a lot of quantum
mechanical particles or something like
that clearly it would be smarter to
divide the utility in pieces and divide
it up between the different universes
just like we divide energy or something
like that in which case the total energy
is conserved likewise the total utility
is conserved when you when you Branch
the wave function of the universe and to
that extent there's no effect that many
worlds has on practical reason and
morality
um
and thought of it another way so I'm a
little confused by the way James when
you say billions of future me's I'm not
exactly sure what that means but I think
I don't like it I think that this is
saying you know in if in again a single
Universe ontology you're thinking of
your future self and many worlds has big
metaphysical implications it says there
are many future people who count your
present self as their past self and but
they're different people again this is
what I always say about many worlds all
those people are different
but they're all thinner in a very
quantitative sense you know the worlds
they live in are tinier fractions of the
net total of the world out there so I
don't think it's a good thing to think
of them as billions of future copies of
yourself in a way that is
distinguishable from many possible
copies of yourself that have different
probabilities of experiencing different
things in a single Universe version of
quantum mechanics having said all that
as I say in something deeply hidden if
you want to try to cook up something to
cook up a version of Ethics or morality
for which many worlds does have an
implication you can do that and the way
that I came up with is you know imagine
that you you had some ethical principle
that said a certain kind of thing is
just absolutely bad in the sense that
it's not okay if it ever ever ever
happens like this is a completely silly
example but what if when you measure the
spin of a particle that would be 50 15
conventional quantum mechanics you had
an ethical principle that if anyone ever
measured spin up that would be an
entirely impermissible moral disaster to
measure spin up obviously this is a bad
example okay but keep that in mind the
point is that if that were your moral
principle you would behave differently
in many worlds versus a purely
stochastic version of quantum mechanics
because in the stochastic version you
would say there's a 50 chance this
impermissible thing happens and a 50
chance it doesn't so that's bad I don't
want to do it but okay at least there's
a 50 chance that it doesn't happen
whereas in many worlds there's a hundred
percent chance that the bad thing
happens in one world
and 100 chance it hap it doesn't happen
in another world but if your moral
principle is if it ever happens that is
an impermissible disaster then many
worlds says don't ever measure that spin
okay whereas
in the sarcastic world there's only a 50
chance that this really doesn't that
this really happens this terrible thing
again this is entirely cooked up just to
give you a way that many worlds could
matter and that's why I think it doesn't
matter but maybe I don't know the future
theory of morality Lexus realized that
it is actually like that somehow and
many worlds does matter
Jessica Napier says what was your
upbringing like you seem to have an
endless amount of curiosity and
fearlessness about trying out ideas
making guesses and adjusting and so on
without your ego getting bruised along
the way I think my ego gets screwed all
the time but I do think it's important
to Jessica to uh make guesses and adjust
and so on and she continues as a primary
school teacher these are attributes I
try to encourage in my students but
sometimes they want to be told what to
think or they're so afraid of getting
the answer wrong of their curiosity
shuts down the adults in your life play
a role in bringing out these great
qualities you know I don't know I had
various great helpful adults in my life
but I think that this particular aspect
of
um not being too afraid of being wrong
um as far as I know this was just my
idea not anything that I got is a
particular lesson from anyone else but
you know and I I don't want to sort of
personalize it too much in the sense
that I don't think that the right way to
get out I agree with the problem I agree
that students are afraid of getting the
answer wrong they want to be told what
to think Etc these are absolutely true
aspects of students and I think that it
would be better if we could somehow
encourage them to do otherwise but I
don't necessarily think that the right
way to conceptualize how to do that is
let's get the right adults telling them
to do it you know the the system is kind
of set up to make them think that way
you know we give kids grades and those
grades can be very impactful they're
high stakes so it's not wrong for the
student to care about their grades right
and if they care about their grades they
don't want to be wrong
that's that's that's what we trained
them to do when they're very very young
they don't know any better and they're
happy to like say a lot of things and
learn as Judea Pearl said babies are
just out there making causal maps of the
universe that's what they're doing
they're touching things and doing
experiments and learning about things
and it that gradually becomes harder to
do and a lot is it because we don't
reward them for doing it so what I would
if if this were my goal in life to
improve our upbringing of kids in the
way to make them more curious what I
would do is not look for more inspiring
role models from adults but to adjust
the system in ways that rewarded
curiosity and play without punishing
being wrong as often and I and I say
that you know without too much
conviction because I know that grades
are important and they're motivating as
well as fear inducing and also you know
not everyone can get into graduate
school so we need some some GPA to look
at and things like that right so there
are roles for these evaluations it's
okay to evaluate people it's not okay to
make them afraid of failure and I don't
know how to thread that needle perfectly
well
tomash gajosh says I'm excited about the
launch of the biggest ideas in the
universe I'm just reading the simple
harmonic oscillator part where you start
with a ball rolling on a frictionless
parabolic valley but by equation 3.8 you
jump to talking about oscillating
particles and state that the initial
velocity will depend on the mass of the
particle represented by the oscillator
you could relate it to the initial
position and potential by thinking about
energy conservation
in our ball at in the valley system the
maximum speed reached at the okay I'm
gonna not gonna read the whole question
it's kind of hard to keep in your mind
unless you've read the book the point is
I can give the answer very very quickly
I'm just trying to help out the book
readers here
um there's a section in the book where I
talk about a ball rolling on a hill okay
and if it's literally a ball rolling
literally on a hill you calculate the
potential energy in terms of the height
of the hill and there's a formula for
the potential energy the potential
energy is the mass of the ball times the
height of the Hill times the
acceleration due to gravity MGH I got
the order of those wrong but you know
what I mean h is the height G is the
acceleration m is the mass of the
particle and then the kinetic energy is
one half MV squared
so the total energy has just an overall
factor of M out there and it it actually
turns out not to matter so that's that's
where the the origin of this question is
coming from why should it depend on the
mass but very often physicists will
change variables to something more
convenient so rather than writing MGH
Mass
acceleration due to gravity height they
will just write V of X okay so they're
absorbing the mass and the acceleration
due to gravity times the height into one
thing called the potential at every
point and then the potential energy at
every Point itself doesn't depend on the
mass okay because we absorbed it in
there so when you're writing in terms of
those variables you cannot simply take
out the Mass from the whole thing and
treat it as an irrelevant external
parameter it will enter into your
equations so you can choose to do it
that way or not it's up to you but
depending on which variables you use the
answer will or will not depend on the
mass in some way
okay I'm going to combine two questions
together Nicholas Chapman says why is
the electron charge quantized
and Francis day asks I listened to a
podcast about the electron today
that is great people are listening to
podcasts about the electron that's my
editorial comment here one of the
physicists on it said that the question
of why the electron has a negative
charge that exactly matches the positive
charge on a proton is still a mystery
and it struck me that the other time
this question is relevant is that the
Big Bang where the matter antimatter
asymmetry problem is not yet explained
is there any chance that these two
things could be related could positrons
have become quarks and balance things
out well so let me answer first the wise
electron charge quantize question
because it depends on what you mean by
quantized I mean obviously every
electron has the same charge that's one
aspect of quantization and that's
actually very answerable it's because
what electrons are is excitations in the
electron field there's a famous story
about Richard Feynman and John Wheeler
where wheeler calls up Feynman in the
middle of the night and says I know why
all the electrons have the same charge
it's because they're all the same
electron and this is the origin of his
idea that you could think of positrons
as electrons moving backward in time
people love to tell that story
but it's not right wheeler was not
correct it's not all the same electron
they're all vibrations in the electron
field five minute wheeler we're kind of
wondering in the back of their minds
these are still the early days of
quantum field Theory whether they could
do better than Quantum field Theory and
replace it with a theory of particles
but these days no we know that it really
is the field that is driving everything
and the reason why all electrons have
the same charge because they're all part
of the electron field but that is not
enough to tell you why the charge in the
electron field is exactly equal in
magnitude and opposite in sign to the
charge in the proton field or the
combined charges of the two up quarks
and the down Quark that go into making a
proton that is something that we don't
have the once and for all final answer
for in the 1970s and 80s when a lot of
work was put into developing Grand
unified theories where you would unify
the electric weak force with the strong
nuclear force one of the nice things
about those theories is they could
provide an answer to why electrons and
protons have the same but opposite
charges because they were part of a
unified story to tell but we don't know
if Grand unified theories are true maybe
they're not so there's other
possibilities out there there are
something called anomalies
in the gauge symmetries of particle
physics that seem to give you rep give
you relationships between the charges of
different particles I'm not uh I forget
whether we that's enough I don't think
that's enough to say that protons and
electrons have to have the same charge
but there's a relationship between them
if you want the anomalies to cancel but
that's only one sort of relationship so
you could add new particles in there and
change it in different ways so I think
that the answer is we're not sure yet
about that as far as matter anti-matter
asymmetry I don't think that that's the
same problem they may in some way be
related but only because their problems
that we don't know the answer to and you
know we don't know what the initial
conditions were at the early universe
both Grand unified theories and other uh
theories of beyond the standard model
particle physics like neutrino masses
and so forth may end up being very
important for explaining the matter
anti-matter asymmetry and they may also
be important for explaining the charges
on the proton and the electron beyond
that I would not want to say very much
specific
Lars says I listened to several Popular
Science podcasts and also follow a few
YouTube channels it seems to me that
most of this content is within the realm
of physics and Natural Sciences with
some philosophy and maybe AI research
here and there what do you think it is
that makes these topics so appealing and
interesting to the General Public
I mean I want to say that because
they're really cool
physics Natural Sciences philosophy AI
research that many things are cool of
course if you look at YouTube or
podcasts overall science of any sort is
not dominating anybody's list right
there's a lot more murder or self-help
podcasts out there than there are
science podcasts I mean maybe the
question is different kinds of Science
Biology or chemistry or Material Science
versus cosmology big questions kind of
things and part of it is you have to
give the people something interesting
you can't just complain that there's
more of one than the other I know you're
not making this complaint but there are
people who complain you know why doesn't
my particular subfield of science get
more attention to popular media so you
gotta kind of go out there and do it it
might be true I don't actually know that
this is correct but it might be true
that the kind of people who like those
kinds of science are also oriented or at
least interested in popularizing it
right sharing it broadly that might be
part of it I don't know the other part
might just be that you don't need a lot
of background to appreciate questions
like where did the universe come from or
will a computer become intelligent
someday right those are easy questions
to ask it goes back to physics being
simple in some way so I don't know I
don't I don't actually complain about
this kind of thing I don't worry about
that especially because I think that in
terms of getting new people interested
in science it almost doesn't matter what
kind of science they become interested
in you can ask a lot of graduate
students doing physics what first got
them interested in science and even if
they're doing Atomic physics or plasma
or physics or whatever it might very
well have been
um the elegant Universe by Brian Green
talking about String Theory or just
watching science fiction shows or
something like that it's the idea of
Science and chasing down these big
questions and trying to answer them that
gets people interested almost
irrespective of what the actual subject
matter is
Douglas long says we just rolled in to
visit my son in Pasadena just north of
Caltech this is the first time we will
walk across the campus for repeats
without the possibility of running into
you so I can now ask this question just
wondering if if that were to happen
would you welcome a hello from one of
your patrons I always planned on just
giving you a curtain odd if it ever
happened sure I'm very happy to say hi
to anyone who supports mindscape on
patreon I'm even happy to say hi to
those listeners out there who don't
support on patreon that's how generous I
am I mean I'm probably doing something
and don't have a lot of time to chit
chat or discuss one's favorite
interpretation of quantum mechanics but
certainly very very happy just to say hi
uh and you know look I greatly
appreciate that there are listeners and
there are supporters I think it's
wonderful and I try to do the best job I
can so that you enjoy it and very happy
to get feedback on that
olafur schooly Magnuson says does
anti-matter appear naturally here on
Earth yeah absolutely I think that
sometimes people get an idea that
antimatter is mysterious or hard to find
or something like that it's really not
you know anti-matter was first
discovered by Carl Anderson in cosmic
rays but the cosmic rays themselves were
not anti-matter they were high energy
protons that are cosmic rays coming down
and hitting the atmosphere and creating
a shower of Elementary particles some of
which were positrons anti-electrons and
some of which were muons and anti-muons
also so that's one obvious source of
course in some sense that's coming from
the sky but many kinds of radioactivity
give off anti-matter particles there's
the rare rare rare event where you can
give off a positron but it's extremely
common for radioactive decays to give
off anti-neutrinos so yeah antimatter
appears here on Earth all the time it
doesn't last very long and the
individual anti-particle if it's a
neutrino will just Escape away if it's a
positron and we'll hit electron and
annihilate but they're definitely
produced
Jason K says Duncan experiment you are
living you are a living being whose
entire existence is within a black hole
the everyday reality of your universe is
ruled by quantum physics would an equal
equally civilization an equally Advanced
civilization I suppose this means as
ours
discover classical physics and
four-dimensional space-time outside the
black hole so two things one is as we
said earlier there's plenty of classical
physics inside the black hole there's
absolutely no reason to think that
somehow the world is more obviously
quantum mechanical just because you're
inside a black hole you wouldn't even
notice if the black hole were big enough
you would have an end date you have an
expiration date much like you would if
the universe were collapsing to a big
crunch but the other thing is you know
in some sense would you be able to
extrapolate to the outside of the black
hole well sure for one thing you can see
it right light can come in from outside
the black hole and be observed by you
and your telescope you are inside the
black hole looking to the external world
and you can see outside the black hole
no problem you just can't get there
before you hit the singularity the final
thing is that you know in some sense
this is what we do all the time in
science we discover local laws of
physics we extrapolate relate them to
the regimes that we don't see in some
sense it's like talking about the
Multiverse or something like that we
have laws of physics equations that we
believe and trust because we test them
within the regime we can test them and
then we say if they continue to be true
in other regimes that it implies this
other stuff right so four-dimensional
space time outside the black hole would
be part of that of course again it's not
exactly the same in this case because in
the black hole you can just see it
directly but the idea of believing the
laws of physics that you believe are
true is one that applies in many
different sets of circumstances
Jonathan Goodson says I've devised a
different Quantum interpretation that in
my uneducated opinion addresses the
measurement problem explains the
two-slid experiment and cures world
hunger okay maybe some exaggeration
there I realize that the odds are
overwhelming that the interpretation is
mistaken but I'm still eager to have it
reviewed by someone knowledgeable I have
no personal contacts in the world of
physics or Academia I'm not asking that
you critique the interpretation since I
don't think that's what you intend amas
to be but if you or me what strategy
would you adopt to find a professional
who'd be willing to look over your idea
honestly when people ask me questions
like that I usually just point them to
the internet there are absolutely forums
out there quora is one uh there's
certain Forums on Reddit there's just
physics forms if you just go to Google
and look for physics forums there are
people who are interested in talking
about physics of course it's the
internet so you can't always believe
that your uh interlocutor is on the ball
you'll get a wide range of people with
different levels of expertise but you
might find people who are willing to
talk to you and discuss the idea but you
know let me say the other thing and I
hope this has taken in the spirit in
which it's intended
um what are the chances that if you're
not an expert you have come up with a
good Quantum interpretation that none of
the experts have come up with right uh
are you reading foundations of physics
and the British Journal of the
philosophy of science have you figured
out and learned about all the known
interpretations of quantum mechanics
whether it's many worlds or pilot wave
theories or cubism or objective collapse
models or relational quantum mechanics
have you been reading the literature and
listened to talks online about people
debating the relative merits of these
things you know if so then it sounds
like you are pretty educated and if not
then why are you asking experts to
critique your interpretation right I
mean you haven't done the work to
understand what is already
understandable so you know I think that
a lot of people faced with problems in
physics make a leap to saying well I'm
going to solve this problem in physics
which is fine it's a good ambitious
ambition to have but it's much more
productive to First learn everything you
can right to really do the work if
you're going to ask other people to do
the work to understand your stuff then
your responsibility is to do the work to
understand their stuff first and so I
think that once you do that you'll be
able to critique it yourself which is my
much more useful than asking random
people on the internet to do it
Keith says JJ redick's podcast has had
some great interviews with the 76ers
Stars Joel embiid and recently with
former star Ben Simmons
JJ pointed out that Ben Simmons despite
the extreme criticism he has faced for
his shooting led the NBA by far in
three-point shot creation for others on
top of being an elite Defender and all
the other things that are not
specifically shooting what are some of
the analogous phenomena in physics
research where some individual metric
like citations is important but maybe
overweighted at the expense of other
contributions mentoring good Public
Communication Etc yeah that's a great
question I think that the way that it
would be more you you phrased it in a
very clever and fun way the sort of more
standard down-to-earth way of phrasing
it is what kind of academics are good
citizens not just producing their own
work but helping other kinds of work and
I think that extends uh like you
mentioned mentoring in good Public
Communication but even to the writing of
papers you know I remember once in there
was a study that was done in astronomy
uh it was this was decades ago but it
was who was acknowledged the most who
was given thanks the most in the largest
number of papers published in the
astrophysical journal right I do think
that is extremely important as part of
the system that creates good scientific
results I think that we Far Over
emphasize the specific contributions or
achievements of this or that individual
person and completely forget about the
huge support system that goes into doing
this whether it's having your own
students in your group your postdocs
helping you having colleagues that can
help you Etc so I think that when it
comes to promoting hiring uh
acknowledging the work of scientists and
other kinds of academics it would be
better we'd all be better off if more
effort we're given or more consideration
we're given attention we're given to
being a good citizen being the kind of
person who not only does good work but
makes other people's work even better
having said that it's really hard to
quantify right I mean it's even hard to
quantify research success but at least
citations are something it's not it's
very far from perfect but at least it's
a little bit of a measure on how much
impact you've had whereas helping other
people to come up with high citable
papers is something that's very very
hard to quantify so I think that you
just have to face up to the challenge of
that okay it's hard to quantify still
you got to do it you got to try to do it
I think that that is very important and
you know that is one of the reasons why
when people are hired or promoted Etc we
don't just look at their list of
Publications and their citations we also
ask for expert opinions letters of
recommendation or letters of evaluation
from people who are well known in the
field in and they can say things like
this person has been a good citizen
making things happen in various ways so
I agree with the spirit of the question
which is that helping others in those
ways is a crucial part of getting
science done at the top levels
Marco tauser says as I understand it
decoherence is nothing more than
entanglement run amok moreover little
things dico here all the time as they
entangle with their environments and yet
wise people yourself included talk about
entanglement being a precious resource
usually in the context of quantum
information what gives how can it be
precious and also common as dirt yeah
this is a very good question I'm glad
you are asking it and the short answer
is decoherence is not just entanglement
decoherence is entanglement with the
environment okay so the background
picture we have here is that there are
systems where we can actually exactly
talk about what part of the system is
doing what thing and then there's the
environment which is sort of everything
else in the universe that kind of is a
the noise in the background that you
keep bumping into the air in the room
the photons in the room you know various
things would count as the environment is
a little bit
subjective what counts as the system
what counts with the environment but I
think the way to think about it is for
different problems you would be
interested in you might be able to
pinpoint for this context here's the
system I'm thinking about here is the
environment so decoherence is not just
entanglement decalherence is
entanglement with the environment and
typically if you're doing things in the
standard way the environment has many
many degrees of freedom right the
photons in a room there's a lot of
photons out there and what that means is
that when you become entangled with the
environment that's usually an
irreversible process there are too many
moving Parts in the environment so that
you can't undo it you cannot control it
you've lost control it's like scrambling
an egg hard to unscramble the egg right
and in fact literally the entropy goes
up when you become entangled with the
environment so that's a kind of
entanglement decoherence that is
irreversible and this is why in the many
worlds version of quantum mechanics it
represents a branching of the wave
function because different parts of your
system are now separated from each other
by being entangled with their
environment whereas the entanglement
that is considered to be a precious
resource is entanglement between
different parts of your system different
parts that you're trying to keep track
of that you're crucially interested in
so if you have a quantum computer you
have some qubits okay and you're
supposed to be able to read out the
qubits it's not Avogadro's number of
particles just bumping into each other
in some thermal State it's a specific
set of variables that you can measure
and you want those to be entangled in a
very specific way that you can then
control manipulate you know run an
algorithm on the quantum computer and
the one of the deep issues here is that
we don't generally get into talking
about this but remember earlier on in
the AMA I mentioned that uh what whether
a state is entangled or not depends on
how you divide that state up in
subsystems right and so it's not like
there are entangled States and
unentangled states there are subsystems
of states that are entangled or not
and in fact it goes beyond that if you
have
if you think of the environment as
basically performing a measurement okay
which is again what many worlds would do
and I think that what any other even if
it's not many worlds any sensible
version of quantum mechanics would think
of becoming entangled with the
environment becoming decohered as
effectively performing a measurement
then you can break the entanglement that
other subsystems have if you have once
you do a measurement if you have you
know two particles that are entangled
with each other okay and so let's say
their spins are anti-aligned so you
don't know what either spin is but you
know that the spin of one is opposite
the spin of the other but then you
measure the spin of one so now it is not
entangled with the other one anymore you
have broken that entanglement it's still
correlated because you've measured the
spin of one and you know what the spin
of the other one is but there's no
entanglement because the whole thing is
not in a superposition anymore you just
have one spin pointing One Direction the
other spin pointing the other direction
no quantum mechanical connection between
them so that process of becoming
entangled with the environment actually
breaks the entanglement between other
parts of your system and that can be bad
if you're trying to keep that
entanglement there as part of a Quantum
computation or something like that
tarun says congratulations on the recent
launch of your new book I imagine that
this is
this is perfectly suited to someone like
me who wishes to go beyond the Popular
Science treatment of modern physics but
did not study the subject at University
however I read the first two books in
Leonard suskin's theoretical minimum
series on classical mechanics and
quantum mechanics and I'm currently
working my way through the Third on
special relativity and classical field
Theory how do your biggest ideas books
compare and would you still recommend
them to someone in my position
so unsurprisingly yes I would still
recommend them uh you know I know
suskin's books very well let us asking
former mindscape guest I I even blurbed
uh at least the first one maybe others
as well uh yeah others as well I do I'm
pretty sure that's true um and they're
great I can highly recommend them Lenny
is a master of the material but the
spirit of those books is a little bit
different I mean they're similar to my
books in that they're trying to teach
you physics from the ground up and they
do the equations but Lenny's is more
like a conventional Physics course just
sort of softened up a little bit for
people who are not necessarily going to
become physics Majors or something like
that they're still teaching you a lot of
the down-to-earth manipulations that you
would need to try to solve the equations
and all that entails whereas my books
are really just trying to get to the
good stuff just teaching the ideas not
trying to teach you the manipulations
you would need to be a professional
physicist and therefore we get to go
much faster we can we can on the the one
hand dwell on some of the deep
philosophical issues and on the other
hand just still get very far very
quickly so I think that Lenny has a new
book coming out in the theoretical
minimum series on general relativity
which is like book I don't know four or
five in this in the series I'm not sure
but general relativity is in my book one
because we can just go much faster and
so there's only going to be three books
in mind there will be plenty of things
in my book that are just not going to be
in his again because we can go faster so
not dwelling on how to diagonalize a
hamiltonian or anything like that in
book two we're just going to do Quantum
field Theory and renormalization in book
three we're going to do complexity and
emergence and it's really just giving
you a glimpse of the ideas of modern
physics in the quickest and most
digestible way so if you think that's
interesting I'd recommend buying the
books
Peter gallet says we hear a lot lately
about the dangers of human extinction
but the world is Rife with human anguish
and Agony if Extinction would mean an
end to suffering for all time is there a
case to be made that Extinction might be
the more more moral choice
you know there's always a case to be
made but I think that in this case the
case is pretty terrible
um for one thing I don't agree that the
world is Rife with human anguish and
Agony at least if that's the end of your
sentence I think that the world is also
Rife with joy and Triumph in human
accomplishment and furthermore there
might be a lot more of that in the
future you know I have a good time
making a podcast I don't want the world
to end and human humankind to be
extinguished uh so that I can make my
podcast anymore that is one very very
tiny consideration but it's the kind of
consideration that you multiply by
several billion and I think there's a
very good case to be made that
Extinction would be bad if nothing else
even if people really were all miserable
Extinction removes the chance of any
change in the future right so even if
you were much more serious about saying
that humankind had just you know no joy
in it whatsoever I think that uh it
would still be true that you should not
extinguish it because maybe there that
will happen further down the road Road
and you don't want to eliminate that
possibility
Sandro Stuckey says if the large-scale
structure of the universe arose out of
quantum fluctuations near the Big Bang
does that mean according to the many
world's interpretation that there's an
infinite number of universes each with a
different large-scale structure
corresponding to a different Quantum
eigenstate and if so what caused the
superposition of all these states to
decohere so I want to clean up a couple
things here it's a different Quantum
State it's not a different Quantum
eigenstate not all Quantum states are
eigenstates eigenstates is a specific
kind of quantum state that has a
definite value of a certain observable
quantity so you can have an eigenstate
of energy or an eigenstated position but
the generic state is not an eigenstate
of any familiar well-known observable so
that's one thing uh
but yes but the basic answer is yeah oh
sorry the other thing is it may it might
not be an infinite number of universes
there could be a lot of universes but
whether the number of universes is
infinite is a technical thing that we
don't really know about but the basic
answer to the question is yes if you
believe in many worlds
and you think that the origin of cosmic
perturbations is in Quantum fluctuations
in the early universe as it would be
true in the inflationary Universe
scenario but also in other scenarios
then yeah there absolutely are other
universes out there where the
distribution of quantum fluctuations was
different so the distribution of
specific galaxies and stars and things
like that is completely different from
Branch to branch of the wave function so
what caused superposition to decohere
you know it's the same thing as always
does the environment whatever you count
that to be you could just say all the
photons in the microwave background
there you go that's an environment
you're not keeping track of all those
photons I actually wrote a paper with
Kim body and Jason Pollock on the how
this works out during inflation how
things decohere with each other because
as usual lots of physicists are kind of
slap Dash in their applications of
quantum mechanics so in the discourse
about inflation they often treat
different regions with different values
of quantum fluctuations is sort of as if
they were magically being measured by
something right but they're not of
course being magically measured but they
are Deco hearing so you have to sort of
sit down and think about what is Deco
hearing and what is the environment uh
and there's various things that act as
an environment you know modes of all the
quantum Fields outside your horizon can
act as an environment short scale modes
of photons and things like that inside
your horizon connect with the
environment so there's various things
that will cause you to decohere at some
point and what one should mention that
there is something called the decoherent
histories formalism that was created by
people like Griffiths and omnis and
hartle and Gelman and what they try to
do is address this fuzziness that arises
in thinking about the coherence as being
entanglement with the environment under
conditions when you don't necessarily
know what the environment is so they
give a more General and robust
definition of what it means for
different histories of the universe to
decohere that doesn't require a specific
carving out of the environment versus
the system they will get the same
answers in the cases where it works but
it's a little bit more General
high-powered formalism so it can be done
if that's what you want to do
Frank Layman says what is it about the
universe that the second derivative of
position tends to be really important
but the third derivative not so much
basically the moment you introduce me to
Dirk which is the third derivative of
position I wanted to know
why I haven't heard more about this
concept same goes even more for snap
crackle and pop those are the fourth
fifth and sixth derivatives with respect
to time
can you imagine a physical application
of crackle that isn't trivial or
designed just to get a bewildered
chuckle out of undergrads so there's two
different questions here but they're
both good so I'm gonna I'm gonna tackle
them both
um for the the latter question physical
application of crackle you know I I sort
of make fun of snap crackle and pop and
I did that in the biggest ideas in the
universe videos and several people
chimed in in the comments and correctly
pointed out that even if physicists
don't care about this Engineers often do
they're sort of different physical
effects in you know a train or an
airplane or whatever depending on not
just the acceleration but all the higher
derivatives of acceleration also so I
absolutely can imagine physical
applications of these ideas now the
deeper question about why the universe
cares about the second derivative of a
position namely the acceleration but not
the third derivative you know the cheap
answer to that is the laws of physics as
Isaac Newton handed them to us and more
or less we're following in his footsteps
here say that the state of a system is
given by the position and the velocity
so if you can have a formula that helps
you figure out the acceleration you know
everything right in that formula for
Newton is f equals m a force is mass
times acceleration you don't need
anything beyond that
um but you do need position and velocity
and the reason why is because there's no
absolute position or absolute velocity
right everywhere in the universe the
laws of physics are the same at any
velocity relative to something else the
laws of physics are the same that is not
true for acceleration acceleration is
the first of these quantities where you
can absolutely measure it right you know
whether you're being accelerated or not
according to traditional classical
physics
now you're still allowed to say okay why
is traditional classical physics like
that that's a more subtle question and I
think that the thing to say is it here's
the way in which it is subtle
if you have a set of differential
equations so equations like the
equations of motion for classical
mechanics you can always write them as
purely first derivative equations you
never have to use the second derivative
and in fact this is exactly what
hamiltonian mechanics does so rather
than saying you have X for position and
x dot is velocity and X double dot is
acceleration where dot means derivative
with respect to time you can just say I
define y equals x dot
and then rather than having X double dot
is the acceleration y dot is the
acceleration and all of your equations
for both X and Y have no more than first
derivatives in them now there's no
second derivatives anywhere so you can
absolutely do that for ordinary
classical mechanics you never need
second derivatives you can write them
all as first order equations first
derivative equations but then the
question is why is it also useful to
write them as equations with second
order in derivatives and that's
basically the question of why do we live
in position space not in momentum space
why do we treat position and momentum so
differently that's a highly non-trivial
question that nobody knows the answer to
I have some ideas but uh it's one we
usually just take for granted rather
than trying to solve
siraj Rajan says what are your thoughts
on the idea of humanity evolving into
virtual Minds proposed by HBO's
Westworld I haven't followed Westworld
that much since the first couple of
Seasons so I'm not quite sure what is
what is happening there you know I'm I'm
a believer that Consciousness can arise
in all sorts of different substrates so
I have no trouble believing that
artificial intelligence could become
conscious I do have trouble believing
that Humanity can evolve into it and
that's not because of Any mystical
specialness of humanity I think that
once you are an artificial mind or a
virtual mind you will be different than
what you and I think of as human I think
that human beings are very very
can not controlled but affected
determined
um embedded in the fact that we have
bodies okay having a body is crucial to
being a human being the body not only
embodies our our minds and our various
metabolic processes it also gives us
motivation to do various things we get
hungry we get thirsty we get tired right
if none of those issues are there in the
virtual reality then we're a very
different thing than we actual human
beings are so I really think that people
haven't thought very deeply about what
kinds of Minds there would be in the
virtual world you can always try to mock
up a simulation of hunger and thirst and
bodies Etc and try to make it as human
as possible but would you want to do
that I mean maybe you don't want to do
that I don't know maybe that's just a
bad idea and you could come up with a
better system so I am not sure that uh
the TV slash movie slash novel idea that
we human beings are going to basically
transport ourselves more or less
unaltered into a virtual realm is the
right way of thinking about it
Paul Hess says do you think there's a
rock bottom fundamental makeup of the
universe such as perhaps the quantum
wave function or some layer below that
or do you think it's more likely that
there is no most fundamental construct
and instead as the saying goes Turtles
all the way down
well I do think that there is a
fundamental Rock Bottom makeup of the
universe there's the universe whatever
that is I don't know that we're
necessarily close to figuring it out or
we might be it might be some kind of
wave function it might just be quantum
mechanics is the right fundamental
framework or it might not be but there's
something the universe does right and we
might be close to figuring out or not
but in principle it's figureoutable I
think I think that the Universe has
given us no indication whatsoever that
it is somehow unintelligible exactly the
opposite the universe is really revealed
an enormous number of its secrets to us
so I think that whatever the description
is I'm not going to say when we're going
to find it but I think it's out there
lurking somewhere
Ezra parzebok says not sure if you've
discussed this important topic publicly
but how did the cats do with their move
to Baltimore
I'm pretty sure I have discussed this
topic publicly so I'm not going to dwell
on it but you know the cats are doing
fine caliban the boy Kitty uh adopted
right away he's very very chill Ariel
the girl kitty is much more High Strung
it's taken her a long time she was
traumatized by the move and she hid
under various blankets and things like
that for a long time but now she's
almost completely back to normal sadly
we're in an apartment and we're gonna
move again into a house and so there's
gonna be one more bit of trauma but the
house is so nice and has so many big
places to run around I'm sure that both
kitties are going to be very very happy
once that move happens
Rob Petro says if I am interested in
trying to popularize computer science
and spread the good news to a broader
audience than the students at my
University what advice do you have why
do you think physics has been so
successful popularization while CS has
paled in comparison
um so I guess I already did say a little
bit about this just a minute ago but I
don't know I think that CS has been
pretty good at popularization I think
that people are pretty aware of AI and
you know various puzzles in computer
science and things like that
um I don't know how to compare them in
any objective way if you're interested
in trying to popularize you know again
there's a million different ways of
doing it I don't think there's any one
right format I think that part of the
trick to popularization is that
different people will respond
differently some want to see things on
YouTube or whatever someone to listen on
podcasts someone to read someone to do
demonstrations someone it's short and
simple some want it long and Company
located and you need that kind of
pluralistic approach to be successful I
have no special advice along these lines
because you know actually even though I
do a lot of communication Etc I am not
uh an academic expert in the science of
communication I think that is uh a field
that someone can be an expert in I just
kind of do what I like doing and hope
that the chips fall where they may so
I'm not always very helpful to giving
other people advice about how they can
do it I do think that you know maybe
there's some reflection there you know
do the things that you would have found
interesting right you know do what you
want to do and your passion will come
through and people will catch on to it
Doug Dugan says is there any area of
research that you think should receive
more attention conversely do researchers
spend too much time on any one topic EG
the search for subatomic particles
I don't think people spend too much time
on the search for subatomic particles I
think that if you go into typical
physics departments that's a minority
Pursuit as we've been talking about not
every subfield within science gets equal
publicity so you hear a lot about the
search for a subatomic particles but
that's not what most working physicists
are involved in I certainly do think
that there are fields that should
receive more attention namely all the
ones that I'm interested in
whether they are foundations of physics
or complexity Theory or emergence or
whatever it is
fluctuation theorems and non-equilibrium
statistical mechanics I like all those
things I think other people should like
them too but I get it that not everyone
has the same interests I do so again I'm
interested in a broad ecosystem where
everyone is enthusiastic about their own
stuff and we see where it goes now
having said that those are all easy
things to say at some point the rubber
hits the road you have to actually
choose who to hire into your physics
department right as a member of a
physics department that is going to be
hiring people I'm part of this
conversation and we we the I don't know
how clear it is from the outside but the
faculty members in the physics
departments as in other departments take
this responsibility super duper
seriously you know we talk to each other
what are the fields in which we should
grow what are the possibilities of
breakthroughs what are the growing young
Fields what are the fields where we have
strength and can do better all of these
things are taken very very seriously by
grown-up faculty members and so they try
to do their judgment as best as they can
when it comes to uh hiring new people
Etc uh having said that there is a kind
of conservatism among academics right
you know there's certain sub-fields that
have been successful and
um High Prestige for a long time and
it's very easy to just keep doing those
over and over again it is harder to see
the value in a field that is sort of a
new upstart field right so that's why
you know I pointed out when the Nobel
Prize just came out for these people who
are doing experiments in quantum
entanglement these experiments were not
super duper uh high priority when they
were originally done okay it was like
sort of a niche kind of weird thing and
still many people many Quantum uh many
physics departments don't have people
working in those fields of quantum
information Quantum experiments
entanglement things like that so there
is some effort that needs to be put into
convincing a bunch of people who've been
doing things a certain way for a certain
number of decades that they should look
at newer areas that are very exciting
the the problem is that old areas that
are well established have well
understood criteria for Success right if
you're doing experiments in astronomy
looking at the cosmic microwave
background we know exactly how to do
that we know what we're looking for we
know what would constitute a wonderful
Discovery if you're doing
experiments in fluctuation theorems and
non-equilibrium statistical mechanics
that's a much smaller area it has not
been going on for as long and you have
to do some sales pitch to your
um colleagues in the physics department
to say this will be really important
someday right and that's kind of okay
that's how it's supposed to work there
are some things people get enthusiastic
about that turn out to be completely
useless so you have to make that sales
pitch so I would I would like a little
bit more of uh openness to new ideas and
young Fields but I understand why the
arrangement is what it is right now
yohim as a priority question as I
understand it each Photon from the CMB
has been traveling billions of years
before reaching us it must have been
deflected by all the gravity of the
material and energy it came across
during its travels I'm aware of the
calibration of the CMB effort by
backtracking photons through the
universe as we know it in light to the
discoveries of jwst of large previously
unknown structures forming very early in
the universe how can we be certain that
the distribution of the temperature
fluctuation of the CMB is correct and
that possible features such as Hawking
points aren't scrambled by these
displacements well this is a very good
question but it's a very quantitative
question okay the numbers actually
matter you know the discoveries from
jwst of uh larger than expected galaxies
are still tiny tiny variations from the
overall picture right they're still
quite compatible with the general idea
that the fluctuations in density at
Early times were very small and have
grown over time it's not a major
rethinking of the way that we thought
about the Big Bang model or the growth
of large-scale structure that's one
thing to keep in mind the other is that
there will be deflection of light from
the CMB by gravitational
lensing and things like that in fact I
wrote a paper here's an amusing
mindscape attached story I wrote a paper
when I was a grad student or maybe when
I was a postdoc with my uh grad school
colleague Ted Pine on second order
gravitational perturbations of the
cosmic microwave background long before
anyone serve these things so by second
order we mean there is some gravity
there's some perturbation to start with
and then you perturb it again for
example you have some perturbation at
the surface of less scattering where you
make the CMB and then you perturb It
Again by traveling through an
inhomogeneous universe so we presented
one way of actually calculating it that
uh maybe not the most
computationally efficient way in
retrospect but with you know it's
important to be first not just to be
perfect and so the paper is is cited and
used and things like that and an example
of that is exactly what you're talking
about the mixing up of the location of
different things by gravitational
lensing
that's one of the effects that we
identified and the mindscape connection
there is the Ted Pine after graduate
school he did not pursue an academic
career but rather started a band and his
band euphonic is the band that uh whose
song is the intro and outro songs for
mindscape so the mindscape theme music
was composed by Ted Pine who I also
collaborated with on that CMB and
isotropy paper but anyway
um to answer the question a little bit
more directly
the kinds of deflections that you get
through photons passing through
gravitational lensing from large-scale
structure Etc exist but are typically on
very small scales so cosmologists know
this when you look at CMB fluctuations
on very large scales it's irrelevant
it's just not a big deal large scales
that is to say large angles on the sky
most of the work that we've done
determining cosmological parameters from
CMB observations take advantage of these
large-scale fluctuations in the CMB the
place where the gravitational lensing
will be important is for smaller scale
perturbations and people know that
that's important and they're using that
that is one way to learn about the
distribution of density fluctuations
throughout the history of the universe
you know you also even if the initial
perturbations the jwst is looking at are
bigger than expected they're still not
as big as the more modern more recent
fluctuations in density with Galaxy
using clusters and all that stuff so my
impression is that most of the relevant
lensing happens at later times not at
super early times
slippery snake says I used to be a moral
constructivist but encountered David
Roberts's explanation for why he quit
before finishing his PhD in philosophy
the main idea being it's not moral
principles but moral agents that matter
most are agents more important than
principles and if so does moral
constructivism matter so I'm probably
not going to give a satisfactory answer
to this uh but I'll say two things
number one I have no idea what it means
to be a moral agent unless you have some
moral principles like how do we know who
the moral agents are I mean I I presume
a moral agent is one that acts morally
According to some principles right so I
I just don't get the distinction here
and the other one is you know if so does
moral constructivism matter
again I don't quite see what the
relationship there is a moral agent is
going to act in some way
um
is that way objectively figured out by
reason or by the universe or is it
constructed in some more subjective
human way so I think that moral
constructivism can be completely
relevant even if your focus is on moral
agents rather than principles now it
might be true that there is some way of
looking at morality and moral guidelines
that is more useful by focusing on moral
agents than moral principles that might
be true but I just don't know I'm not
exactly sure of what David Roberts or
anyone else is trying to say about that
but I don't think there's a deep
fundamental distinction there so it
might be at best a practical kind of
usefulness distinction
Spencer Hargis says Darwin and others
provided an explanation for how the
fruitfulness of living things could have
emerged naturally over time without
divine intervention now that space time
seems to be multiplying as well it seems
natural to ask whether the fruitfulness
of space-time and the conservation of
its energy could also have been
optimized over cosmological time by a
process of selection as a physics fan
I'm curious to know how this concept
strikes you is it a sort of obvious
question which you and your students and
colleagues are already discussing over
drinks well the idea that laws of
physics evolve over time is certainly
one that has been discussed by lots of
people in lots of different ways you
know in some very obvious way the
cosmological Multiverse idea proposes
the different parts of the universe have
different laws of physics and depending
on your criteria for Reproductive
success maybe that is an example of this
in a more direct way Lis Mullen former
mindscape guest uh proposed precisely a
theory that he calls cosmological
natural selection or Cosmic natural
selection his idea was at the center of
black holes you would create a new
universe and for some reason which is
more or less magical the new universe
you create has slightly different laws
of physics in it okay this idea never
really caught on for two reasons I think
one is that the mechanism by which you
made a new universe inside a black hole
and the mechanism by which that new
universe has slightly different laws of
physics was just never specified like
there's no known reason why physics
should act that way we just think that
what happens in black holes is you make
a singularity not a new universe that
could be wrong and people think
otherwise but that's the usual way of
thinking so this is just part of one's
setting one's credences in uh new
theories and the other the other thing
is that if at least naively
straightforwardly not thinking very hard
what that mechanism would do would seem
to optimize for creating more black
holes right using the analogy with
natural selection
you want to re you know you're not up
natural selection doesn't optimize
success you know in any sort of vague
way it specifically optimizes
reproductive success sending your genome
onto future Generations okay by having
kids and having them survive so it would
seem that the relevant laws of physics
would be the laws of physics that let
you make new universes I.E make lots of
black holes and it seems to me that our
universe is nowhere close to optimizing
the number of black holes that it could
make right we have black holes they
exist but the number of black holes in
our universe as far as we know is way
smaller than the number of stars or
planets or whatever and it doesn't seem
that hard to imagine different laws of
physics that would make it much easier
to make black holes so if anything uh
the data seem to be against this
particular idea having said that there's
other ways that laws of physics could
evolve besides smolen's Theory and I'm
actually thinking about that myself
these days in the concept in the context
of quantum mechanics but you know it's
all very far from uh connecting with
reality yet so I wouldn't hold out too
much hope that this is going to be
something established very soon anytime
soon
Dan O'Neill says do you feel physicalism
in your bones for example when in
conversation with another human being
are you comfortably able to think of
them as a purely physical system or
would you have to stop and remind
yourself of this fact
well on the one hand yes I'm comfortably
able to think of them as a purely
physical system on the other hand I
don't feel any need to stop and remind
myself of that fact because as a good
poetic naturalist I recognize that
there's more than one way to talk about
a system like a human being in the
universe human beings can be physical
systems and they can also be human
beings with wants and desires and all
that stuff I think all that is true I do
feel it in my bones I feel no objection
to it at any intuitive level
Rue Phillips says there's a great new
documentary on Netflix called a trip to
Infinity complete with multiple
mindscape guests there's a really moving
part where Alan Lightman talks about how
as a young person he was very depressed
and sad about being a speck in an
indifferent Universe doomed to
nothingness
but then he found love and his
perspective completely changed it didn't
change what was true but what was true
for him personally and gave him meaning
in life for your listeners to struggle
with this Cosmic perspective of being a
speck in a universe that doesn't care
what advice would you give any
personable personal relatable
experiences you can share
well you know again I I always feel
inadequate trying to give advice about
these kinds of things because every
individual person is different every
person is going to respond to different
kinds of things I never really felt bad
about being a speck in a giant Universe
it's true the universe is very big
doesn't really care about me that much
that never really bothered me why should
I care about the fact that the universe
doesn't care about me very much my
concerns are much smaller scale in terms
of my everyday life than the great
expanse of space and time throughout the
Universe I care about the people I
interact with and can affect in some way
whether it's through personal
interactions face to face or through
podcasts or through books or whatever
students in my classes that's what I
care about right
trying to make the actual Earth a better
place is more important to me than the
fact that most of the cubic centimeters
in the universe are empty and don't have
life in them at all uh having said that
you know there's there it's absolutely a
good question to ask you know how should
we shape Our Lives what does give them
meaning what does matter I did a podcast
about this I did a whole podcast on
meaning uh solo podcast a couple years
ago so you can check out my ideas there
and I you know tentatively suggested
that we can think about meaningfulness
as arising from fighting against what is
easiest or um just comes without any
effort right what are the ways in which
by exerting our agency we can change the
world from its course and to make it be
something better and that might be as
small as making your children or nieces
and nephews Happy by giving them a
present or something as large as come
combating climate change or something
like that there's various ways in which
you can make changes in the world in a
positive direction they don't have to be
Cosmic scale that's okay I don't I don't
see why that should be the natural
comparison much more human scale things
are usually what matter to people most
like falling in love that's a perfectly
good example
JS says is complexity Observer dependent
we say that a coin flip is simple
because we allow ourselves to model it
probabilistically and the probability
distribution of a coin flip is simple
but to laplace's demon who can model the
Dynamics exactly and presumably can
predict specific outcomes exactly
wouldn't a coin flip in fact be very
complex in general does the world appear
more complex to a more sophisticated
Observer
so the short answer here is it
completely depends on your definition of
complexity which is not something we
have a once and for all definition for
like life or like intelligence as we
talked about earlier complexity is
something that has different aspects
that will be relevant under different
circumstances uh having said all that
you know there's absolutely a kind of
complexity that is Observer dependent
that involves a core screening but you
don't even have to think like weird
things that are ill-defined like
complexity just think about entropy
right entropy is pretty well defined and
we know what it is and laplace's Demon
wouldn't need it because laplace's demon
sees every particle and doing everything
entropy comes about by coarse graining
by saying that a whole bunch of
microstates for all intents and purposes
form the same macro state they're
indistinguishable from each other the
laplace's demon every microstate is
distinguishable from each other so they
don't need to talk about entropy the
pasta's demon doesn't see an arrow of
time they just see different states at
different moments that's all that they
see so to that extent yes in exactly the
same way to an observer who only sees
coarse grained features of the universe
then they will think about complexity in
a different way than an extremely
hypothetical and in fact completely
physically implausible Observer who sees
every single microstate
Gregory klistnick says what's your
Credence on the feasibility of building
a high resolution neutrino telescope
that could see beyond the CMB and what
sorts of interesting things would you
hope to see there
well I think that my Credence is pretty
low uh I think it would be awesome just
to detect the cosmic neutrino background
which we've not been able to do so for
those of you who don't know there's the
course the cosmic microwave background
the photons from The Big Bang and we can
only use those to see back to the
surface of last scattering the moment in
the history of the universe when the
universe went from being opaque to being
transparent about 380 000 years after
the Big Bang there is also a neutrino
background we're quite sure that it's
there we can sort of implicitly see the
importance of those neutrinos to the
cosmic energy budget so it's got to be
there but they're very hard to detect
because neutrinos are just very hard to
detect and these are especially low
energy neutrinos
but we can imagine it you know what if
you could see the neutrinos and in that
case you'd be able to see beyond the
surface of last scattering right because
neutrinos were never in an opaque
environment neutrinos were just freely
streaming so you would see way back to a
much earlier time in the history of the
universe but even though that's true as
a function of times you would see back
to the first fraction of a second after
the big bang I think that what you would
actually see is pretty much the same as
you would see in the microwave
background because in terms of actual
distance that you're looking further you
know you're looking billions of light
years back to see the surface of last
scattering and then a couple extra
hundred thousand light years from that
to see what the neutrinos came from and
I don't think that physical conditions
are going to be that different a hundred
thousand years or 300 000 years light
years away from the surface of less
scattering that we actually see today so
it'd be great to see it I love it I
don't know how to actually
technologically do it but I wouldn't
imagine any completely astonishing
discoveries coming from it that are not
already implicit in our knowledge of
cosmology
Simon Carter says when promoting your
new book how do you decide which
podcasts talk shows to go on
I don't have a system really I will
confess that I turned out a lot of
invitations
since I started my own podcast you know
I used to be on I used to more or less
try to go on podcasts especially if they
were you know young struggling new
podcasters that I would try to go on and
and help and things like that but I only
have a finite bandwidth for doing
podcasty things in my life I have other
things to do I have to teach and do
research and write books and things like
that so now the fact that I'm both
creating my own podcast and you know
preparing for it and all that stuff that
is almost all of my podcast bandwidth
there's a couple of exceptions for
either people who I know or if I have
new book coming out but even for the new
book I have tried to I've had to
restricted to you know the biggest hits
you know the ones would actually do the
most good for me promoting the book
right that's the basic Criterion you
know there's some that I don't want to
go on just because I don't like them and
I don't want to get involved in
arguments or anything like that I just
want to talk about science but mostly
it's just you know what do I get the
biggest bang for the buck because I just
don't have too much time to do other
people's podcasts
Brendan says you and other cosmologists
have stated it could be possible that
time is infinite in both directions past
and future however I've heard some
theologians try to discredit this
consideration by saying if there's an
infinite amount of time in the past you
would never get to today because it
would take an infinite amount of time to
reach the present to me this reasoning
sounds a bit flawed although I'm having
a little trouble articulating the
underlying issues would you be able to
help weigh in on why it is not
necessarily correct to say that the
president would never happen if the past
is infinite in time yeah that's a real
I've heard that argument it's a really
bad argument it's like saying the number
zero can never be obtained because
starting from minus infinity would take
infinitely long to count to zero the
point is you don't start from minus
infinity you just start from whatever
point you want and go in both directions
of time so the part of the philosophy
behind Imagining the time is infinite is
that time is not something that started
right that's those those two ideas time
is in infinite and time started are
incompatible with each other so if time
is infinite there was no starting point
that's the way to think about it and
therefore the idea that you would never
reach the present starting from the
starting point is just a mistake right
from the start
Matt from Sweden says it seems to me
like there have been a few major
theoretical breakthroughs within physics
during the last decades compared to the
early 20th century if so could this be
attributed to the low-hanging fruits
have already been picked or simply that
we don't have another 21st century
Einstein or moxplunk
so it's definitely not the latter it is
definitely not that we don't have
another 21st century Einstein or
whatever both because we do have an
enormous number of super smart talented
people right now and also because other
people would have done what Einstein and
Planck did if they had not been around
okay so it's not like they were just
singular Geniuses back at the time it's
much closer to the the other idea that
the low-hanging fruit has already been
picked but let's emphasize it wasn't
super duper low-hanging fruit things
like the theory of relativity or the Big
Bang model or quantum mechanics okay
um I think the way to think about it is
sort of a little bit backwards from the
way that it is usually put it is not
that the last few decades have been slow
it's that the first half of the 20th
century was just absolutely amazing and
atypical in the history of science okay
the idea that you would have multiple
scientific revolutions all during a few
decade period which which we did with
relativity special and general
relativity quantum mechanics Quantum
field Theory Big Bang Theory modern
particle physics all of these things in
a really short period of time you just
can't get used to that like the history
of science has never been like that we
really did get lucky uh or the people
who lived at that time were lucky to be
living in that time that was so exciting
in terms of physical discoveries so the
second half of the 20th century is it
was more or less in fundamental physics
where I live a story of coming to terms
with the discoveries that were made in
the first half of the 20th century you
know we already had Quantum field Theory
but we had to figure out how to use it
we already had the Big Bang Theory but
we had to find the microwave background
and figure out how to measure the
density parameter and things like that
we already have quantum mechanics but
we're still working on getting the
foundations right you know all of those
things and that's just Perfectly Natural
that's that's normal science that's how
things are it could change right away
right I mean at any time a big new
discovery or idea could tip over the
Apple card but I think that the pro rate
of progress that we've had in recent
years is just much more normal and
ordinary than uh the one what we got
spoiled with in the first half of the
20th century
okay I'm going to group together two
questions
George Robinson says all of the
beginning quantum mechanics that I
learned is based on linear equations
like the Schrodinger equation but in
many disciplines the physics becomes
non-linear like in non-linear Optics
where or how does non-linear Behavior
emerge and Eric stromquist says what do
you think of the apparent conflict
between Quantum linearity and classical
chaos for example a certain YouTuber
said that quantum mechanics does not
correctly reproduce the Dynamics of
classical chaotic systems my guess is
that within any given observer's branch
of the wave function the observable
Quantum Dynamics can be consistent with
non-linear chaos because the states
observable within the branch are
typically mixed thanks to entanglement
with things in other branches of the
universal wave function
so I don't think it's exactly that but I
think that you know there's there's
something that is on the right track
here I mean the short answer to both
questions is classical mechanics can be
highly non-linear quantum mechanics is
linear but classical mechanics also
emerges from quantum mechanics it's a
limit it's a limiting case so there's
nothing inconsistent about that you can
have overall linear Dynamics and quantum
mechanics and so there's no chaos in
quantum mechanics if what you're doing
is following the evolution of the wave
function of the universe everything is
linear and it's actually pretty simple
but we're not following that right we're
following the evolution of branches of
the wave function which are little tiny
particular slices of the wave function
and there is a limiting case there's a
set of situations set of physical
circumstances in which you get a
classical limit from quantum mechanics
and then things can be perfectly chaotic
I give you an example the uh the famous
example is the tumbling of the Moon
Hyperion okay a Hyperion is a moon of
Saturn which has a very lumpy uneven
shape and you can do the math and figure
out that the tumbling across the
different axes of this moon is chaotic
classically chaotic okay you don't it's
not it's not hard to create uh chaotic
systems in classical mechanics and so if
you didn't know about D coherence and
things like that and you did the quantum
mechanics of Hyperion so you said well
its orientation has a wave function and
that wave function will generally spread
with time the quantum analog of saying
that the classical behavior is chaotic
is to say that the quantum wave function
spreads out by a lot so this isn't the
spread of the center of mass location of
the Moon a Hyperion it's the orientation
so you should just see a big fuzzy
spherical blob when you look at Hyperion
okay if all you were doing was
following the evolution of its Quantum
wave function in isolation but as wojak
Zurich and others have pointed out
you're not doing that it is not in
isolation it's in a quantum mechanical
Universe where things decohere so the
moon Hyperion is constantly being
monitored by radiation from the outside
world which becomes entangled with it
and essentially decoheres the wave
function of the orientation
and therefore when you look at the Moon
it is actually in some orientation it is
not a wave function all spread out all
over the place but nevertheless if you
followed in our observable branch of the
wave function the orientation of that
Moon it would follow a chaotic
trajectory again there's nothing
incompatible about those two things
Jeffrey Seagal says in the podcast with
Kiara mingarelli she mentions that there
is at least one supermassive black hole
the center of every massive Galaxy does
that mean that some smaller galaxies
don't have black holes at their centers
and is there a correlation between
central black hole size and the size of
the Galaxy so interestingly yes there is
a correlation between central black hole
size and the size of the Galaxy and this
is a bit mysterious people don't
completely understand the origin and
evolution of central black holes as far
as smaller galaxies are concerned it's
unclear it's unclear to me I'm not an
expert maybe some expert can chime in
here but I think that the answer is you
wouldn't necessarily know if there was a
central black hole at the middle of
every small Galaxy because maybe the
black holes are there but they're
smaller so they're harder to find right
but it certainly is an interesting topic
of astrophysical research and just so no
one gets the wrong idea
as Kiara said as we talked about in the
podcast the black holes of the center of
galaxies are really really small
compared to the galaxies themselves it's
not that the black hole somehow governs
the evolution of the Galaxy that is not
the way it goes it's the other way
around it's the Galaxy that is affecting
the evolution of the black hole in some
way such that bigger Galaxies have
bigger black holes in them that's that's
what the research is
okay the last question for this AMA
comes from Roman leventov who says is
there's a sort of physics thinking that
is widely useful for solving problems in
business and life not just in Natural
Sciences if yes do you think physics
thinking is reducible to the knowledge
of physics ontology plus logic plus
solid epistemology or do you think there
is still something else to physics
thinking did you attempt to teach read
read to teach readers physics thinking
directly in the biggest ideas so yeah I
do think that there's a sort of physics
thinking and I do try to teach it in the
biggest ideas I I somewhat jokingly talk
about these spherical cow velocity uh
philosophy ah it's getting late in the
AMA the talking is becoming hard anyway
um yes there's a way that physicists
think and do their research and to me
the essence of it besides just being
science obviously there's scientific
thinking right but specifically physics
thinking as we've already mentioned
earlier on it comes down to the search
for the correct simplifications right
what are the features of the system that
you can ignore that you can get rid of
and I think that the reason why physics
works so well is that it's often pretty
clear in physics cases what you can
ignore how you can model a system by
some much much simpler system and still
capture some of the essence of Its
Behavior
for other systems where things can be
much more complicated that kind of
thinking may or may not be useful so you
know when I'm thinking about the physics
of democracy I'm certainly not saying
that the right way to think about
democracy is all to think of it like a
physics system what I'm saying is that
thinking of it like a physics system
might give certain kinds of insights
under the right circumstances so think
like a physicist by all means look for
the simplifications try to find simple
toy models that give a lot of the
behavior and then add in the
complications later but don't be
surprised if that doesn't work if it
works that's great if it doesn't work
use some other method that's a good
lesson for Life Beyond physics thinking
so that's a perfectly good way to end
this AMA thanks as always everyone who
listens to the AMA especially the
patreon supporters who make it possible
thanks for everyone to listening hope
that uh you everyone buys the books
that's what I hope I think that would
make everyone's life little bit better
the holidays are coming right you need
gifts it's don't just buy one book for
yourself don't you know Bogart all the
books all the wisdom send gifts to all
of your friends that would be great and
uh talk to you next month
[Music]